new york city
there's a video
people being arrested for trying to
enter a museum without proof of
vaccination and one of the people being
arrested appears to be a child i don't
know the full details on this there's
probably some nuance sometimes they're
not really getting arrested they're
detained but my understanding is that
they're trying to claim trespassing as
we've seen with many of these other
instances meanwhile over in the uk they
have completely done away with all of
their coveted restrictions at least it's
my understanding the bbc says masks are
out people can now start coming back to
work and their vaccine passports
gone
it's interesting that the us is not
following suit after the supreme court
ruling saying biden didn't have the
authority to mandate any of this vaccine
stuff carhartt says we're gonna do it
anyway or at least that's what's being
reported and starbucks says nah we're
not gonna do that i jokingly referred to
that as my pressure campaign against
starbucks working because i said i was
gonna hire the people from the local
starbucks to basically protest the
mandates and then all of a sudden it
happened no i'm kidding but we got we
got a lot to talk about too
we got joe biden who's under fire for
saying that the upcoming election will
be illegitimate because the democrats
weren't able to force through their
voter overhaul bill didn't work and
we're going to be talking about
censorship big tech and following up on
a conversation about getter with no no
no none other than the ceo of gab and
founder andrew torba how's it going man
great to be here you want to pull your
mic up a little bit closer
and uh just introduce yourself man so uh
i'm the ceo of gav.com the home of free
speech on the internet um i'm a father
i'm a husband and uh i'm here to save
free speech on the internet it's that
simple
so uh we talked with a couple different
ceos recently we had uh rumble the video
platform a lot of their terms of service
are very similar to the big tech
platforms then we had the ceo of getter
they have very similar uh rules but i
guess gab is the one place where your
only rule is what the first amendment
yeah i actually brought a copy of our
terms of service right here right
congress shall make no law representing
an establishment of religion or
prohibiting the free exercise of or
abridgement of the freedom of speech
right so it's really that simple if it's
allowed by the first amendment it is
allowed on gab all right well there's a
lot we gotta we got we gotta break down
in that one and there's a lot of history
about what what has happened to gab with
institutions and censorship and all the
stuff that you guys have been targeted
with so we'll get into all that so
thanks for coming man sure plus plus the
news in general plus we got uh we got
luke here i was hoping you would take
out a piece of paper that would say i
could do whatever i want i would have
appreciated that one
before we begin i definitely want to
shout out everyone in the house who
participated in our first jiu jitsu
class uh it went very very well it's our
kind of unofficial fight club who needs
security when we all need no jiu jitsu
i'm kidding i'm being fishy this year
and i also wanted to remind people that
it was never about the new normal it was
always about the new world order and if
you agree and want to wear this uniform
out there to the general public and send
this message to them you can by getting
this shirt on
thebestpoliticoshorts.com because you do
i'm here thank you so much this should
be a great conversation and i'm really
looking forward to it oh my gosh uh hey
guys check out the cast castle vlog i
wanted to shout that out from yesterday
it was very funny sheamus and chris are
a magical team they're really hilarious
guys and i got to work with them on a
fun um movie skit yesterday so check it
out and i mean crossland andrew great to
see you man finally to meet you in
person great to be here in a long time
we've been working together in parallel
systems so this is really cool and uh
follow me ian crossland.net if you want
to i'm really excited to have andrew the
night after we had the gentleman from
getter so i'm stoked to hear what cool
free speech we're going to talk about
tonight before we get started head over
to timcast.com and become a member to
get access to exclusive members only
podcasts from this show the tim castro
podcast we're going to have a special
segment at 11 p.m tonight you're not
going to want to miss it because that's
where we we talk about uh we we call it
the uncensored podcast show we're
basically swearing a lot and we we just
we have no rules uh but as a member
you're helping support this show you're
helping support all of our journalists
you're helping support our it crew and
all the tech and all the administrative
work so it is greatly appreciated your
memberships are basically make all of
this possible and functioning but don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends let's get into that
first story we got this tweet here from
libs of tick tock nypd arrest multiple
people including a young child for
trying to enter a museum without proof
of vaccination
this i think shows you the extreme
degrees some of these u.s cities are
willing to go at the same time check
this out
face mask rules and covet passes to end
in england they're also saying that
people can start working from home so
here's my question what what is this
contrast how are we
we're america
all right we we declared independence
from from them
because we want freedom and now over
there in the uk they're like yeah we're
gonna get rid of all this stuff no covet
passes freedom and then here in the
united states we're split apart by
people who want mandates and want to
push it to the extreme and people who
don't well some people just want to
trample on freedom and squeeze that
lemon to the last drop as of course
cases are going down dramatically the uk
is obviously getting rid of all of their
mandates their lockdowns and
restrictions this is also the kind of
dichotomy that's happening right now uh
between that hipster clothing company uh
what what is what is it called
car car and starbucks
yuppie hipsters uh wear that all the
time just for the record and that was
appropriated from us rural folks
exactly but but you know the video that
we saw today just shows you the
absurdity i mean we don't even see this
kind of larger push for the vaccine like
we did before because a lot of people
are realizing a lot of bigger truths
here and it wasn't just the united
kingdom it was also the czech republic
that announced that vax mandates are
totally gone in their country because
the president called them nonsense from
the start those are his own words so
we're seeing a big unraveling which
we've been talking about for weeks on
this program i've been saying hey a lot
of things are going to change very
dramatically in 2022 and this is it and
it's happening in front of our eyes and
this to me is the last drop that this
kind of establishment has to squeeze
everything they can out of this tragedy
that unfolded on the world yeah i think
what we're seeing is a representation of
the two different realities that we both
live in right now we have two different
sides of reality for you know large
swaths of the population population
including countries and of course we're
seeing it here in the united states with
states right so we see people by
hundreds of thousands that are fleeing
these blue states places like new york
going to florida going to texas going to
places where they have freedom and they
aren't being told that they can't enter
a store they're gonna have a child
arrested this is absurd right so this
this type of stuff is actually gonna
drive more and more people to the places
where they will get freedom and it's
gonna accelerate the balkanization i
think we're seeing in the united states
right now and there are people who don't
mind living in these in these places
they don't think twice they they they
walk up to their 7-eleven parking lot
and the nice man comes and gives them
their shot and gives them their card and
they're happy with it and there are
celebrities who advocate for that my
position is it always has been you need
sound advice from a trusted medical
professional hey that's what youtube
says you're supposed to say yet for some
reason there are high-profile
celebrities who advocate for you to not
do that but to just go into a 7-eleven
parking lot which is the craziest thing
to me but hey hey look you know what my
position is live and not live if you
live in new york or california or cook
county the chicagoland area and you want
to just you know do whatever do whatever
you want man don't look at me i mean
i'll tell you what i think but people
are going to be staying and other people
are going to be going and that that
hyper polarization was seen in this
country you mentioned vulcanization this
is accelerating it
yeah i think it's inevitable right i
think uh you know when you have a
country where people live in these two
different spheres these these two
different realities um what do we share
in common anymore what makes us united i
mean just a you know a piece of paper
right is this what makes us united
because there's people that don't even
believe in this anymore and you're
holding the declaration of independence
in the constitution but and i'll point
this out
we
people on the right all the time are
like you know tim pool's a liberal or
he's a centrist or center left and i'm
like i don't think those words matter
anymore right because what what this is
really about is do you believe in
reality or not right you you can have a
bunch of views on on religion that i
don't have but we both look at the news
we both break things down and say hey
this thing is true and this thing isn't
right censorship is happening we both
are more likely to believe in aspects of
freedom that the left will completely
ignore or disregard even if we have some
disagreements the left believes
i quote unquote the left you know that
the establishment left they believe
outright falsehoods and they like almost
it's almost like they want to i can't
russia gate for years jesse smallett
covington all of these things i should
stop and give you pause and be like
maybe that's not correct so we have a
ton of people on this show just so
happens that it is more so the the
colloquial right
and it's not that we're politically
right-wing on this show certainly we all
have varying opinions but it's because
we all agree on what's true so i don't
know what left and right even means at
this point but there if there are two
groups of people that completely view
the world in two different ways they're
not going to work together i feel like
it's more nuanced than do you do you
believe in reality or not more that it's
more the question is
how do you perceive reality and it's
different for every individual although
it seems like it's f 50 50 ish like most
people kind of see reality in a certain
way similarly in another group i don't
even think it's that simple that it's
two groups but it's like it's so many
different groups of people i see what
you're saying but what i mean
specifically is russiagate was fake
donald trump did not collude with russia
that was a false narrative from the
press and it seems to be fake yeah seems
to me no it's definitively fake from
what the proof from the evidence we've
see well i've seen it seems to be i'm
not gonna lay my hat on any of this
that's i i think that's i think that's
actually smart of you because you you
haven't done the research i've done i i
can i can definitively say i've seen
enough that beyond a reasonable doubt it
is true trump did not do this for you
you trust me you've seen some stuff good
point so that's that's actually a fair
assessment but if you're someone who
says after five years of all the lies
how much do they spend on the mueller
investigation it pulls up nothing then
they lie about the ukraine phone call
they lie about everything trump does at
a certain point if you still believe
that and you still believe them it has
to be willful right i think ultimately
what we're seeing here is what is actual
reality right what what where reality
exists and then what is the reality that
the establishment regime wants us to
believe exists right and in in the
reality that exists is the truth and in
that reality if you separate the
democrat versus republican stuff and you
just talk about you know basic facts of
life most people whether you're democrat
or public you want to provide for your
family you want to protect your family
you want to live in a safe society where
you can go to the store without having
your child arrested right i think
democrat or republican i think we can
agree on that type of stuff and this
divide that they this this illusion that
they have they're the uniparty they
share the values they have a unified
objective the regime is against us it's
us versus the regime it's not democrat
versus republican because ultimately
when you break down what you know
democrats and republicans as human
beings it's human beings versus these
technocratic tyrants right that is the
ultimate you know dichotomy here of
what's going on
absolutely
whatever it lives is absolutely it's
gonna look right
it's absolutely
either you believe in freedom or the
subjugation of the free human spirit and
there are still some people holding out
but i would say by and large i think a
lot of people are realizing that they
were scammed that they were lied to that
they were not being told the truth these
this video that we just saw happened in
new york city the state should we should
play it to be honest yeah yeah well
there's
talking there's there's cursing in there
so we might have to audio but but this
is video of of activists doing the
sit-ins that we literally saw decades
ago when of course segregation was legal
here in the united states discrimination
based on people's own personal medical
advice is absolutely deplorable it's a
disgusting policy that the nypd is
willingly carrying out on beheads of the
state and there's also reports that the
mother of this child also had cps called
on her so it does seem like the state is
trying to punish all these individuals
all these activists standing up for
their personal liberty for their
individual right to be able to
participate in society without needing
to get government permission a domestic
passport system is absolutely insane and
these people are trying to
institutionalize it and luckily that
battle has been lost i think the the big
domino which is the united kingdom has
fallen more dominoes will fall from here
and when you look at the numbers
especially when it comes to cases the uk
when it comes to cases it looks like
it's about one week ahead of the united
states so and and right now in the uk
the cases are dramatically going down
and a lot of people expect the cases to
go down in the united states because
and when that happens this whole game is
going to be unraveled to the american
public how mad do you think people are
going to be when they were like they
said wear masks they send they said get
vacs they said get two shots get three
shots they still locked us down and then
after we did everything they asked they
just released all the lockdowns and
everyone who disobeyed gets to freely
participate
think about the awakening think about
the awakening of that though if you're
someone who got you know the fourth
booster and wore the mask every day and
stayed home and locked down and all that
stuff and all of a sudden this all ends
what does that do to your psyche right i
don't know man you'd think at this point
people would be like maybe i shouldn't
trust the establishment narrative but
they just keep doing well i think this
is the red pill moment this is it it's
like an evolutionary necessity that
people are exposed to the reality and it
happened to me in 2005 because i was on
the internet making videos and people
were like hey did you know about the
federal reserve did you know about the
military industrial complex and these
were like new words to me i was like
well no but tell me oh my gosh hey
everyone they're like ian you're crazy
but now it's
it's you cannot deny when when people
are injecting you or forcing you to
coercing you to inject yourself and then
you find out that
fill in the blank you might go nuts well
you find out that it you know in the uk
the vax passport's done yeah so there
were people who were told if you want to
participate and go to bars and
restaurants you have to do this and they
said okay and now a few months later
they go actually nah scrap it actually
it's a lesson
it's not about that for me it's not
about the science it's not about the
medical stuff that's that's your
personal business
it's the people who are told if you want
to go out to eat you have to do what we
tell you to do and they did i don't care
if it's wear a fuzzy hat or get a
vaccine the point is the people who
obeyed the government ultimately end up
realizing they shouldn't have they
should have done what was right for them
and if that means going to a doctor and
you know we've had a lot of people on
the show who have been vaccinated
they're older yeah and their doctors
advised it
there's a lot of people who probably
don't care about this and that's the
other important thing you're going to
see a lot of people on the left being
like oh they're so worked up no i
recognize that a good portion of people
probably went to their doctor got a
vaccine and said have a nice day and
never thought twice but there are a lot
of people who are who are just doing
whatever they're told by the state
when they realize
i'll give you an example
there's that guy in a store stalking a
woman screaming is anyone else mad that
we all have to wear masks and she isn't
wearing one
that's exactly who i'm talking about
those people are going to lose it when
they're like no
but i did what i was told yeah they need
um they're gonna need like a safe place
to to regain sanity so there'll be it's
an opportunity to make fun of people and
be like you stupid idiot look how you
fell for that you more and just
make people so angry and hateful but
ultimately i think if we can be
forgiving and kind i was just going to
stay it's an opportunity for empathy
because if we show them empathy then
they will be more open to our ideas and
saying listen
listen next time you know you called us
conspiracy theorists you called us you
know uh extremists and all this stuff
and anti-science and all this stuff and
now you've woken up to this well maybe
next time they'll listen to us if we
show them a little bit of empathy this
time i think that that has a powerful
effect i think a lot of people are going
to go crazy i think those feelings are
going to be exacerbated specifically
when it comes to individuals who are
still locked down i use that word
i know exactly what i'm doing here i
posted i posted a meme on my instagram
page showing a confused blond-haired
bear-chested australian on barbed wire
looking confused and it says australians
watching the uk remove all mask mandates
and and
there's going to be a feeling in
australia in the netherlands being like
why are we still doing this when the
rest of the world didn't do this and i
truly do believe what florida did during
this entire saga was absolutely crucial
when it came to defeating the mandates
and lockdowns here in the united states
if it wasn't for florida if it wasn't
for governor desantis texas followed him
other states followed his lead
specifically saying we're not even going
to implement this here in the first
place and because of that this is why i
think it wasn't uh you know set into
play all throughout the united states
because of him standing up and saying no
other states are saying no right now
other countries are saying no right now
and other countries are going to be
looking on be like hey they get to have
some freedom we want some of that too
let's see what happens with carhartt bbc
reports carhartt facing calls for
boycott over vaccine mandates the
outcry comes amid a fierce debate over
the u.s coveted 19 jabs this month
scotus said the government could not
force large employers to make a covid19
vaccination or weekly testing mandatory
companies including the coffee chain
starbucks have since reversed their
plans but in a recent memo of staff
carhartt leaders said the supreme court
decision had not changed the company
requirements now this is resulting in
many people calling for a boycott i'll
tell you first the funniest thing i love
it i responded to this by saying how
about this if you work for a carhartt
and you don't want to get vaccinated
quit
my my view on this is like i'm not a
communist i'm not going to demand a
private business be forced to employ me
or or you know if if i don't want to
work there i won't but for some reason
the left ragged on me for it
oh and the best part was on reddit they
were like uh but he's right though like
he's he's telling him to quit what's
what's wrong with that yeah i don't
think there's any actual principle for
the most part behind what carhartt is
doing and behind what people uh the the
establishment left and pro-mandate
people believe
it's all tribal if they can make fun of
someone quote unquote on the right
they'll do it even if they they should
be agreeing with it now as for car at
the company
what do you think you think they're
gonna lose money on this deal listen i
know carhartt because ninety percent of
my wardrobe is carhartt right now
wearing car now though oh no absolutely
not we're in milwaukee tonight right
otherwise it would have been right you
could ask my wife she'll confirm this
about 90 percent of my wardrobe is
carhartt you know it's it's rural rugged
blue-collar people working-class people
who are by and large anti-vaccine
mandates so it's total it's an example
of total tone deafness from a
corporation about their core target
demographic and that is a real problem
and it's a problem for us too because we
can't just boycott everything right you
know what am i going to do i'm going to
take all my car clothes now and you know
burn them in the fire pit like
naked right it's like you know i love my
car art stuff and it's it's it really
breaks my heart that they're doing this
but um you know at the same time
it's almost like where are the options
right you know where's the non-wool
company uh out there and it's like it's
almost like everywhere you turn it's
it's every single corporation you cannot
escape it strangely starbucks check this
out from people drops covet vaccine and
testing requirements for employees after
supreme court ruling
out so so i live in west virginia not
too far away from where we do this
production and uh i went to a coffee
shop with my girlfriend we wanted to go
shop local and so we went to this local
shop with a big sign in the door saying
you had to wear a mask and i look behind
me and it's like a hundred feet away
it's longer than it's across the street
and i'm like there's a starbucks right
there they have no mask mandate let's go
there instead i'm gonna go there right
i'm gonna go there um i would rather
give money to the small business but not
if you're in west virginia of all places
supposed to have all this freedom and
you as a private business want me to do
that i'm not gonna cry about it i'm not
gonna go you you crazy uh i'm gonna be
like oh well starbucks it is i guess i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna complain to the
store but i'll tell you this after this
i'm gonna go first thing in the morning
i'm gonna buy a bunch of starbucks for
the whole staff
i don't i don't like the company to be
completely that's the sigh up dude don't
fall for it they make us all angry and
villainous and that's the truth person
to the first person to relax is the
kingdom of britain the king the queen
and the corporations of starbucks they
watched
starbucks do like woke training did it
they shut down for a week because they
wanted to re-educate all of their
employees on specific uh sjw kind of
principles yes and in that instance i
would be like okay i'm not gonna shop
there but when someone does something
right i want to encourage it if
starbucks is saying we're dropping this
i want to go there and say you guys are
awesome i love what you're doing let me
buy some coffee from you do more like
this let starbucks realize that when
they do that woke insanity they lose
customers and when they when they do
write by working class people they gain
customers i talk about this all the time
the most power that we have is our
wallet where we're spending our time and
where we're spending our money that has
the most that is how you vote right that
is the best way to vote and that is what
gets the most action from these
companies is when they see their their
profits go up after making a move like
this they're going to pay attention to
that if starbucks ends up making a bunch
of money retaining employees and uh is
starbuck starbucks publicly traded it is
right yes
if their stock value goes up it's not
just the company it's the shareholders
and they're gonna be like tell starbucks
to do more like this we're making money
it's improving my my portfolio is doing
better and then starbuck's gonna be like
hey the customers have spoken
that's why you reward companies and they
do right you punish them when they do
bad and if the people that have stock
and starbucks have a lot of stock in
starbucks and they're like hey we like
that this company is making us money now
we want all our other investments to
start doing what they're doing exactly
well the principles here matter carhart
has about 5 500 employees starbucks has
over 200 000 but the people working at
carhart now have to make a very tough
decision you know especially if they
can't get this procedure especially if
they have some complications
or if they just personally have
religious values or belief systems that
that complicates this they have to
choose their livelihood over complying
with the whims of a corporation that's
not even liable for a product that
they're forcing them to take that's
disgusting orwellian behavior that
should never be tolerated and they are
facing a lot of backlash they are facing
a lot of boycott and and good um i i
think maybe they were trying to double
down on their yuppie hipsters because it
is blue blue-collar people who do wear
uh their clothes but it's also a lot of
urban hipsters uh as well maybe they're
just trying to appease their they're
kind of
trying to reshift their brand just to be
cool i don't know they didn't have to do
anything yeah that's the point
starbucks doing this
is them
deciding to to make a public
announcement that they had to if they
didn't want to have the mandate they
could have dropped it and said okay
we're not gonna you know they they
they're dropping it they're making that
statement
carhartt or starbucks they could've said
nothing they could have just been like
uh
we'll just do nothing and change nothing
starbucks has had to make that shift
carhartt decided to reinforce and
announce to everybody we're gonna we're
gonna keep doing this so
there it is you know the carhartt has
made their decision at a time when most
of these companies know there's a major
divide in the market
why carhartt
this is the crazy thing to me starbucks
is the woke company and they chose
freedom and carhartt is the
working-class company and they chose
oppression
totally upside down totally upside down
and you know i think this is a perfect
example of of the parallel societies
that we're seeing right they're seeing
two different societies here and two
different sides of the narrative and two
different shifts in what companies are
going to do they're going to have to
start making choices like this every day
and it's going to impact their bottom
line and people need to again vote with
their their dollars that is the most
important thing your time your dollars
that is where you have the power we
actually i made this joke the other
night but we have a vaccine amended on
this show everybody who watches has to
be vaccinated oh yeah so if you're at
home and you're not vaccinated i'm just
kidding
are you thinking about lifting the
mandates i've officially lifted all the
mandates if you're watching at home and
you are not vaccinated and you are not
wearing a mask we're going to allow it
okay because we're we're right there
we're right there with starbucks that's
right
starbucks is going to make a lot of new
hires this year were those of their list
one were those of you listening at home
not wearing a mask
oh my gosh
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'd have to spend
two or three years a bunch of money and
an investigation to get to the bottom of
this yeah
i'm just pretending like we're the
american government wasting time oh
right everybody send us 20 million
dollars and we'll investigate ourselves
this january 6 committee it feels like a
lot of money and a lot of attention on
something that is not that big of a deal
maybe yes like what an amount of
attention and money has been spent on
this one day
relatively non-violent it's like the
monica lewinsky bill clinton scandal in
my opinion i can't say it was relatively
not someone did die some people died so
it was definitely monica lewinsky but it
wasn't like going on there no no the uh
the storming of the storming the
entrance into the capitol one woman died
because she was killed by a cop yeah
right and then i think somebody fell off
the wall and then someone was trampled
someone had a heart attack so cops were
cool let me tell you why they have to
keep this narrative alive they are
trying to demonize 80 million people in
this country that is why they are trying
to keep this narrative alive full stop
you know we all know common sense people
know i think both on the left to right
really wasn't that big of a deal okay
not the biggest not the the deal that
they're making it out to be
they're going to keep dragging this on
and milking this cow for as long as they
can for the purpose of demonizing 80
million people in this country that is
what it's about but you guys want to
know something
you know
when we did a poll of uh our show and
people who watches it was mostly like
moderate libertarian-leaning individuals
they weren't far right or left or
anything just regular kind of people and
then you have a it leans a little bit
more right in some areas than it would
left but we actually had people who
self-identified as socialist and far
left to watch the show some people hate
watch it some people actually like
watching it but um beyond this show
which is
i guess it's a big show
but joe rogan's a really big show when
you have joe rogan
praising james o'keefe and i was that
was that was incredible awesome uh and
joe actually defended me i'm eternally
grateful joe that was i really do
appreciate it he was talking with james
lindsey
joe's a regular guy who leans left i
mean he's pro ubi
the regular people in this country
aren't falling for any stuff anymore the
establishment can come out and scream
january 6 or whatever they want but
regular people are just like yo we don't
believe you you've lost we're not with
you anymore your narrative is gone
cnn's ratings are 90 percent down msnbc
90 down people aren't buying but you
know what makes me nervous did you see
that video of the kids uh i don't know
what country it was in but they were
asking the kids do you i was france i
think you wanted
oh yeah yeah these little six-year-olds
and what do you do if someone's not
vaccinated you call the police you take
away everything from them until they
comply so it was one of the response by
the little girls who was speaking in
france
there has been a de-escalation away from
authority in society but then the
re-kind of brainwashing of children is
happening now that i haven't seen a lot
of but that that video was crazy their
biggest fear is us waking up and stop
the bickering between democrat and
republican left and right and uniting
together against the regime that is
their biggest fear that is why they keep
pumping all these stories on both fox
and cnn constantly with the drama what
did aoc wear on her dress what did she
tweet today all of this nonsense to keep
us distracted and divide it and focused
on batting heads with one another
instead of uniting and batting head
again against the dragon right what do
you think would happen if in 2015 or
like as we're getting in the 2016 cycle
bernie and trump teamed up
that's so awesome because
because the the insurgent populist left
which very much does not get along with
the insurgent populist right but both
despise the establishment the regime the
cathedral
it would have been it that would have
been a a that would have been a
political revolution in this country but
they effectively made sure that you know
bernie he caved he gave right into the
machine and he changed his positions
bernie was the was open he bernie said
open borders is a bad thing for you
three four years later he's like it's a
good thing if bernie stuck to his his
positions and actually worked with with
the right and the right was willing to
work with him the establishment would
have been would have been wiped out but
they're holding on by a thread with this
biden guy who can't think straight and
it's and it's sad it is
let's let's do this let's let's talk
about this let's get into this we have
this story from the wall street journal
biden draws criticism after raising
prospect of illegitimate 2022 election
white house says president wasn't
casting debt on midterm results let's
let's not waste time joe biden was asked
about not getting through two bills
which would overhaul the us election
system he then said that he thinks in
the election in november would be
illegitimate which is an insane thing to
say because if these bills have not been
voted in now then what's he saying about
the 2020 election well jenn sackey comes
out and she goes let me be clear he
wasn't saying that the election would be
illegitimate he's saying what trump did
blah blah blah because then kamala
harris comes out and she goes hold on
there let me finish the election will be
and then she basically backed up
joe biden
joe biden and kamala harris have pushed
the idea that the election will not be
free and fair because they did not get
through their complete voter overhaul
wow it's like a child screaming when
they don't get a candy bar how about
this but he's the president how yes
absolutely you want and you want to talk
about trump arguing about voter fraud
and stuff too i'm not going to play
these games you can't come out and ban
on youtube discussion of donald trump's
opinions and then not so so hold on
there a minute youtube i certainly hope
you start enforcing this against all of
the biden supporters who are going to be
saying this stupid nonsense so they say
they don't want you to say that certain
elections in the past have have been
rigged or whatever that's kind of part
of youtube's events but this is what
about your life future of elections is
okay to say hey maybe
demoralizing to say that stuff though
for the president to be like this
election's not going to be any good
upcoming people won't vote if you say
that dude so don't say that i agree and
uh
i as well as many others have been
critical of trump and many trump
supporters for telling people
that there's effectively you know by
pushing the fraud narrative
it tells people not to bother and then
you see what happens in georgia when the
democrats end up winning two seats they
should not have won but there were
people outside who are saying there's no
point why bother and it's like you need
to go vote man more importantly you need
to vote in the primaries you got to vote
in all your local elections and then you
got to make sure the establishment
uniparty types are removed and this is
our opportunity
i have a feeling come you know next
december i'm going to be very very
disappointed but you know for the time
being i'm going to be like guys primary
everyone democrat republican primary
amal and if you don't like any of that
vote mises caucus dude i think they see
what's coming right they see that the
midterms are going to be a total washout
because people are not happy with
biden's policies his approval rating is
in the tanks so they know their numbers
they have this internal data so they're
trying to see this narrative now and
they're going to be talking about this
and pushing it for the next year so that
when it happens they can pull their
whole russiagate nonsense again well the
election was stolen somebody did
something and they might they might
point a gap by the way because we have
you know almost 100 candidates in the
2022 race on our site that are
organizing raising money building
communities etc and i think we're going
to be an underdog for this for this race
and we make it blamed for
the red wave that is coming i have never
said
donald trump won the 2020 2022 election
i have said in 2020 like in may and
october people are bringing this up that
trump was right about certain issues
pertaining to fraud but that was before
an election took place and there was
like cnn reporting on fraud and stuff
but not widespread fraud i have no
problem arguing with people like steve
bannon having those debates and now
we're at a point where the democrats
pulling a complete 180 and doing
everything they complained republicans
were doing and that's why i'm just like
you can't gaslight me
you can have this conversation i can
look into this i can ask for evidence
but then when you come out and try and
make you think i'm stupid enough to
believe that after a year or longer of
you saying all of these things about
trump then you start saying them sorry
it literally can't work you must believe
these people are dumb as a box of rocks
unfortunately some people are very dumb
but the narrative is not going to work
anymore this is this is also going to be
a red pill moment for a lot of people
they're going to be like wait a minute
aren't the democrats the ones claiming
trump was lying about fraud and then
trump claimed he won and now they're
already starting to push that same exact
narrative yes because they're liars
i think people are going to wake up to
this and be like hey maybe the media is
lying to me i hope more people do to be
honest i feel like the uh
the brain of the american country got
infected by like a parasite when the
federal reserve
performed their coup in 1913 and now
it's like i love i'm looking at it like
it's my wife who has a parasite in her
brain and i'm like i love you you are
everything to me but it's not her
anymore it's something else now but i
still love the corporeal form what am i
supposed to do i want to extract the
parasite i want to reduce the federal
reserve and and create a new economy the
best way to do that is by getting into
things like bitcoin that and that is why
they're freaking out you see them
starting to see this narrative right now
hillary's coming out even trump has come
out against bitcoin right why is that
right so people should start looking
into that because the way you know i was
talking about this before we started the
show bitcoin is free speech money
bitcoin is the only reason that gab
still exists right now because in 2019
when we got banned from everything
payment processors paypal everything we
were still able to accept bitcoin we
didn't need permission from any bank we
didn't need permission from any
corporation or any government to do that
that is how we take down the federal
reserve that woman is a succubus ian and
uh
be careful watch out she's gonna take
everything from you including all your
money but she'll leave you on dedication
forever okay i'm sorry she still
represents a great idea that should be
protected at all costs but to go on this
kind of area when it comes to
cryptocurrencies i think this is why
countries like venezuela and russia have
been talking about developing their own
cryptocurrencies the u.s federal reserve
is also hinting that they may just
create fed coin but just like anything
it's a technology just like the internet
it could be used for good it could be
used for bad and you guys were were
helped by julian assange was helped by
it when he was de-banked major banking
institutions visa mastercard attacked
julian assange and wikileaks because the
cia
ordered them to do so they took down all
of his accounts and he was only able to
raise money with bitcoin which made him
a multi-millionaire so you know
everything has a karmic way of working
out in the world and i think whether
it's it's a psyop or not a psy up
cryptocurrency does represent a
possibility of freeing people just like
the internet did we just have to hope it
doesn't get corrupted it is like the
monetary version of a free speech
network correct it is people's ability
to bypass the establishment their
controls their narratives what i love
most about bitcoin is the stories about
really weird and gross people who became
millionaires and billionaires it's just
like the dude in 2011 who was like i
need a i need a decentralized and you
know secret currency to use for what
reason i wonder and now they're rich
dude i had a guy sleeping on my couch
who's a billionaire right now i'm not
even joking with a bee and he was a bum
he was eating my macaroni and cheese
like microwavable and and
and then i shout out to you i have i i'm
still shocked i don't know exactly what
i'm talking about the dude was like he i
was just like dude you know
i i like
back in the day you know if someone
needed to stay somewhere i was like yeah
i stay at my place this dude was
overstaying his welcome like a mother he
was i was like dude you know maybe you
could go stay at someone else's back
sounds like i don't want to i don't want
to have interest bro remember times 10.
you didn't pay me back remember when max
kaiser i think it was gave alex jones 10
000 bitcoin i was there
you know they say bitcoin is
decentralized but
if you're at the top of it looking down
at the blockchain you're basically
looking at a centralized system of nodes
so it's really centralized not
necessarily no no
at this point you know over this many
years right it has become so
decentralized and that is that is why
you know china has tried to overtake it
with the mining and stuff and they
haven't been successful right every
attempt to take down bitcoin every time
there's an article that comes out
bitcoin is dead oh it's tanking now it's
dead this time there's actually a
website that tracks this it's been like
hundreds of times over the past 13 years
or whatever it is that the reason that i
trust bitcoin so much is not only
because it saved my own business but
also because no central authority
controls it there's not one government
and by the way there are countries now
entire countries that are adopting
bitcoin which is really telling and when
i see the establishment you know both
the left and the right coming out and
attacking it that's when i know that it
is the real deal um you know it is
absolutely decentralized and it is
absolutely the only one that is
decentralized i'm a bitcoin maximalist
myself i believe that bitcoin is the
thing that is going to end these things
like the central bankers the federal
reserve all these things i think it's a
matter of time yeah el salvador uh
implemented it right they're kind of
national currency and the world bank and
the imf started attacking them because
of it yes oh yeah and now they're doing
financially you know better than they
were before they're allowing people to
to of course have the ability to
transact with each other with
cryptocurrency in a non-centralized way
what venezuela and russia have been
developing is literally track trace and
database surveillance correct coins uh
what el salvador has been doing is
completely different and it's going to
be a very important case in looking at
how this is implemented on a national
scale and the larger effects that it's
going to have on their markets which is
truly fascinating i was thinking about
going down there and investigating it
and possibly even moving down there
they're creating uh a tax-free uh
business zone as well which some people
are saying is going to be the next kind
of singapore who knows if it will if it
won't if bitcoin will crash no one knows
no one could predict that but it
certainly is providing a lot of
opportunities outside of the mainline
establishment system which i think is
absolutely great just an aside some
people are saying twitter is down yeah
i can't i can't check twitter hey gab is
not
let me tell you let me take this
opportunity to tell you gab.com gab is
up and running well so you know with
biden
making all of these statements
them trying to walk it back kamalhair is
doubling down
hopefully this double standard is is a
big smack in the face figuratively to a
lot of people
among many other things among the the
covered lockdowns and the vaccine
passports and and all of that stuff
i just i i don't i don't know if i
should be as hopeful that people pay
attention because
when a good example is when lauren
bobert tweeted that biden said trinidad
shabbat of pressure she said biden never
you know fulfilled his promise on
trinidad shabbat pressure
the left's response was her brain broke
what is she trying to say
because they don't actually listen to
what joe biden says so if joe biden
comes out and says this they probably
did not hear it only we did because
we're the ones paying attention so you
have people in this country who don't
pay attention to what's going on and
then go vote and then you have people
who do pay attention and they're called
conspiracy theorists well that's the
problem of censorship and echo chambers
of people just following the same voices
the same ideas the same kind of
viewpoints just regurgitated to them
with different kind of uh points with
them but essentially they're just
regurgitating the same thing doubling
down and be becoming more radicalized uh
this is why censorship needs to be
pushed back at all costs and uh i mean
you're here i have a lot of questions i
want to ask especially about your
algorithm but we could save that no
let's look later let's do it right now i
mean we're talking about so so we were
just talking about how joe biden can
come out and claim the the upcoming
election is going to be illegitimate but
youtube bans and censors those
conversations twitter censored
information on on hunter biden's laptop
which would have changed the results of
the election facebook did the same thing
you andrew are the ceo of gab and i
think are you are you the only uh social
media platform that uses the first
amendment as it's rule book the only one
we are the only free speech platform i
think mines does that too do they yeah
first amendment and it's based on law in
connecticut the state where it's
incorporated so interesting yeah
well good for both of you guys excellent
attitude but let's
let's break this down uh
gab has been attacked they've tried to
shut you down they've gone off you've
gone after your infrastructure
you you you have sitting in front of you
a pocket declaration of independence and
constitution you say it's it's it's if
it doesn't you know if it's if it's
within the first amendment people are
allowed to say it
why are they are the these big tech
companies trying to take a gab offline
right so we are the most no platformed
censored d-platformed whatever you want
to call it startup technology startup in
history we've been banned from both app
stores because apple and google came to
me and they demanded that we censor
things that they didn't like and i said
no absolutely not because you don't make
the same demands of facebook and twitter
you can find hate speech on twitter you
can find hate speech on facebook and i'm
not going to censor it because you're
not making them censor it okay so i
refused to bend the knee and they banned
us from the app stores they actually
banned our entire developer account in
apple's case we've been banned from
banks tim we've been banned from every
payment processor we've been banned from
hosting services right email services
about 30 plus different services all in
all right with all the infrastructure
that it requires to run a social media
website so what we've done over the past
five and a half years since i started
gab is we've built our own people go say
if you don't like it it's the free
market go build your own that's exactly
what we did we are the only platform
that has done that all these other
platforms that are coming out now
they're saying we're the free speech
platform if you look at where their
servers are hosted they're hosting on
amazon if you look at who they depend on
it's apple and google on the app stores
if you look at their terms of service
they have the exact same terms to
service as as facebook as twitter so
it's basically silicon valley but with a
new logo okay and that's not what we're
building what about mines are they on
amazon
at the moment they were on amazon as of
six months ago and i talked to bill and
he was like uh we're moving off amazon i
don't i haven't followed up with them
since that conversation that's the only
way forward is building your own
infrastructure and we've had to build it
all we have our own physical server
hardware racks okay and we have to
physically maintain those and upgrade
those and swap out new hard drives and
and all that type of stuff and that is
just a massive amount of work for what
reason so so they say if you don't like
twitter go make your own and you did and
then all of a sudden different companies
seemingly unrelated sort of knocking out
the support beams from your service
right i i can understand so you
mentioned you know google says hey we
want you to censor certain things said
no so they ban you but what about banks
why did bank ban you well they tried
attacking us from every different angle
from after three weeks after we launched
actually five and a half years ago they
started with the smear campaign right
it's all right it's nazis it's all this
stuff right and that didn't work we kept
growing we kept getting bigger so then
they said okay surely if we ban them
from the app stores then they're not
going to go anywhere right a social
network without an app on the app stores
it's dead in the water and we kept
growing
and then we kept growing and growing and
growing and they said okay we're gonna
take we're gonna go after their bank
accounts we're gonna go after payment
processors and they when they can't
process payments they're done there's no
way a business can exist on the internet
without being able to accept credit
cards or or paypal or all these major
you know payment infrastructures and
thanks to stuff like bitcoin and uh
checks physical checks that people would
mail into our po box so we had old
technology and new technology and that
is what kept us afloat for an entire
year before we were able to build our
own payment system and come up with our
own solution so
you're uh on the forefront the the the
in terms of protecting actual free
speech which means you've got probably a
lot of detestable conversations and
really awful people i'd imagine yeah
it's words on the screen right a lot of
people that i don't agree with a lot of
people that don't like me a lot of
people that say a lot of nasty things
about me and my family and it's allowed
and that's actually how you know that
it's a free speech platform there's uh
there's a parody account of me called
andrew tuba
and i think it's one of the funniest
accounts on gab it's actually one of my
favorite accounts and maybe they don't
know this but i find it hilarious
because you know you see that and and
that is allowed on there you can find
stuff like that on there even about me
the founder the owner right i don't i
don't i i i really don't know if i
should bring it up but people have
mentioned that uh
posts critical of of the getter crew
have been removed is that absolutely
false no that's absolutely funny didn't
do any of that stuff no no absolutely
not oh they they're removing it or we
are no no no no no i've heard
that on getter oh yes yes people have a
question i thought you're saying we were
doing that was like no
no no is that true though
i saw people chatting it and i want to
be careful because if it's if i can't
prove it i don't want to bring it up
what i've heard is anybody that's
critical of miles uh the their
billionaire their chinese billionaire um
who's behind it we had the conversation
about fuentes the other day with the ceo
of getter
and i i
i don't want to drag a specific platform
into this but considering you know jason
miller was just here and it's very
obvious to everybody i didn't find his
response adequate on what rule was
broken by nick fuentes
look man my position has always been
this oliver darcy of cnn interviewed me
in 2018 when they started banning the
alt-right from twitter and i said it's a
dangerous precedent we we always have
been you know as as and i'm going to say
the the
as liberals in this country because i
grew up in chicago in the city i've
always been left-leaning we're always
about free speech and then all of a
sudden twitter is like we're banning
only this group of people and i'm like
if they're not threatening violence if
they're not targeting people even even
to a certain degree an argument about
harassment i'd be willing to accept you
just don't like their opinions well i
don't like their opinions either argue
them like the aclu and they defended
really awful people in skokie illinois
that famous story now they're all not
doing it they're backing away they're
all going full authoritarian
so my position has always been
i recognize nasty people say nasty
things
i think we agree on that but when he
says you know jason miller oh well you
know we didn't want to service his group
the problem he he brought up uh he
opened the door forgetter the problem
was he basically said black lives matter
all banned critical race theorists all
banned
modern progressives all banned
all of these prominent lefting
personalities
what's that lady's name jamila jamil or
something is she that actress woman yeah
she was on she's banned yeah yeah she's
been she posts tonight's racist stuff
if if if gutter wants to have that
standard
then the crazy thing about this is
the modern right in this country today
is posting martin luther king jr quotes
they don't want people to be judged on
the color of their skin
but if you come out like like miller did
and say we're not going to allow anyone
who breaks that rule it's like okay well
that means the republican modern
republican party is going gonna be on
the platform the democrats won't be
right nicholas j fuentes is the canary
in the coal mine with censorship i mean
this kid is 23 years old he has a live
stream from his parents
house and he can't get on a plane
because of his political opinion he
can't access you know he's he's probably
just as banned as we are uh in terms of
platforms now of course you can find him
on gab on like getter and you know
jason's answer is just totally
unacceptable you look at uh getters
terms of service and they ban hate
speech and they make these arbitrary
decisions like banning nick fuentes and
banning people like john miller even uh
you know with no reason and no recourse
and no adjudication um and then they
claim to be a free speech platform it's
a joke i didn't like it when
i asked him what you know luke luke
asked him what rule was broken
specifically well the terms and services
right because he has a list and a number
i was like give me you know give me the
list tell me he didn't he didn't have
one he did clarify there's difference
between terms of service and community
guidelines which for me there's not at
mines for me i i based my community
guidelines were the terms of service but
i understand how you could have two
different things at least that was his
response that's what i got from that
what worried me the most guidelines were
were violated i don't know it's it
sounded like they were just twitter but
a little bit better right a little bit
better and so there's still the inherent
problem that the reason they banned nick
fuentes is because the media said bad
things about him right look for all i
know what the media claims
about him was true for all i know
however i don't really trust the media
so i'm not going to just blindly be like
oh okay you banned him because cnn wrote
an article i'm going to be like uh
you're going to show me some hard proof
because the media doesn't have any
credibility right now he didn't have it
he couldn't give me a specific example
he couldn't give me there was not even a
philosophical reason it was just you
know fuentes said something about who
are gropers here and so then i asked him
what a griper wasn't it he didn't seem
to know that either
and so my my view is if you're going to
ban someone
stand by it be proud of it and not be
able to explain what went wrong how am i
supposed to trust your platform you know
if he had come out and said we banned
him because we believed that apple and
google would remove us from the stores
if we had him on the platform i would
have respected that right but you know
jason is a political strategist that's
what he does he's not a technologist he
doesn't know how to run a social media
company and frankly he's in over his
head i think it's obvious after last
night right uh you know what these
people are doing is they're really
trying to subvert the work that i've
been doing for five and a half years and
the work that we've been doing at gab
and it's really it's us versus the
billionaires so you know you have uh
miles gao who is the chinese billionaire
behind getter you have peter thiel who's
behind rumber rumble and you have
rebecca mercer in the mercer family
who's behind uh parlor what about mines
yeah they're aaron yeah that's it yeah
we got you guys are independent
crowdfunding as well started from the
beginning with nothing and then john
came in bill's dad is half owner of the
company and the three of us it's a
family business just like us yep exactly
mines does have a big mine's just taken
investments in the past we got a 10
million about it two years ago um from
the dude that i don't know how is it all
public information i don't know if i
think about names and all that but he
basically built the the games that yahoo
bought in like 2000 to create yahoo
games that guy came in
um we had uh the guy from overstock yeah
he's the he's previously there is
anything coming with six million about
four years ago but that's i think other
than that it's just we crowdfunded a
million bucks yeah so that's what we did
we did regulation crowdfunding so our
users a nice chunk of our users are
actually stockholders in cab so they
have a piece of the pie and they're our
biggest advocates right um and outside
of that we're funded by you know our gab
pro subscriptions merchandise you know
stuff like this hat um and we now have
advertisement but you know we're not
tracking you creepily like facebook and
stuff did you guys ever have any big
funders coming your way and try to say
hey we're going to give you this money
if you do this and are you willing or
able to disclose the largest kind of
funder is there one guy who's like a
millionaire that gave you guys a million
dollars or you know you don't have to
answer it but i'm just curious i think
our average investment was a thousand
dollars for our regulation crowdfunding
offerings we did have a few bigger angel
investors who and by the way all these
people are users on the site um who put
in i think maybe 100 000 or something as
a part of that overall round of
crowdfunding but anybody was able to
invest i think as low as 200 this was
back in 2017 2018. um we have had people
that have come to me and have tried to
tempt me with money absolutely i've had
you know big hedge fund guys and a lot
of names that a lot of people would
recognize if i said them i'm not going
to do that but you know essentially the
deal was you have to start banning
certain things and you have to start
doing things a little bit differently
and we have to pivot on certain things
and i said unacceptable unacceptable
because the thing that i'm not doing
this for money this is my life's work i
am doing this so that when my children
get older
they have the ability to speak freely on
the internet i want to ensure that my
kids have the same and your kids by the
way and your kids have the same freedoms
that we all grew up with in this country
that is why i do what i do period was
there ever one person that gave over a
million dollars you don't have to
disclose to that no no there was never
one person that gave over a million no i
want to tell you why you you get those
people coming to you making demands
i was thinking about this i'm probably
missing a few pieces of the puzzle but
30 years ago before the internet before
cell phones and 50 years ago and beyond
radio television even newspapers
allowed the the powerful interests to
homogenize morality and culture society
so 30 years ago you have a handful of tv
channels and a growing influence around
you know cable was getting more popular
since the 80s but let's go back to the
70s right you have a handful of channels
maybe like what five
and so
if these five channels decide a certain
idea was unacceptable and they wouldn't
put it on tv anymore they wouldn't
platform it those ideas would start to
die off
people would fall in line with whatever
the mainstream opinion was because they
want to fit in and don't want to be
ostracized with the rise of the internet
now subcultures that the establishment
elites might not like are able to
persist because they can build their own
communities and survive outside of that
ecosystem by finding like-minded
individuals this actually happened in
the 70s it's called the rural purge the
royal tv purge where there were all
these shows like green acres and and
wholesome tv shows about rural life and
rural living those were all purged all
at once from all those major networks
because they didn't want those ideas
anymore they wanted people migrating to
the cities where they can control them
and atomize them like we're seeing our
society become today so now as the
internet expands and different platforms
emerge control of social media control
of these websites
allows them to re-homogenize
are you familiar with the dead internet
theory no what's this this is
it's it's actually a really scary story
but it's actually really simple the idea
is that the internet died a decade ago
and that everything you're encountering
now on the internet is bots
most people don't post anything right
most comments you see are our
algorithmic our bots and manipulation
and the internet is actually not a free
and open space it's just a controlled i
can talk about this big time so this
this is called the one percent rule so
one percent of any given online
community on the internet whether that's
facebook twitter reddit whatever it is
gab
one percent of people are creating
content nine percent are engaging
meaning they're liking their commenting
they're sharing ninety percent of people
are passively consuming content right so
that is where most of the social
engineering these platforms are doing is
going on the passive engagement the
passive people that are just scrolling
the feed and looking at information they
want to decide what you're seeing in
those feeds and they are socially
conditioning and socially engineering
people to have the values that they want
them to have to vote the way that they
want them to have you know i was living
and working in silicon valley and i saw
this stuff firsthand and i said this has
got to stop someone's got to do
something about this there has to be
another way to do this and that's what
inspired me to do what i'm doing
somebody had to do it and i was going to
do it real quick the one percent rule is
part of this but dead internet theory is
basically that we're all under the boot
right that there is no one percent
anymore that it used to be one percent
we're producing everything in 99 we're
watching but now it's that when you go
on reddit and read a comment it was made
by a it's a bot yeah yep that's arpa and
built the internet that's that's
government military it's military tech
the internet so it's not too far out
there and there's a lot of admitted
government sock puppet accounts that are
meant to of course have psychological
warfare impact on the internet to push
certain agendas out there i've been
speaking about this for so long uh but
specifically you know the algorithms not
only create you know echo chambers they
can not only create emotions but they
shape belief systems correct and that's
why i wanted to ask you about your
algorithm do you have an algorithm uh um
like i just signed up on gaba a few
hours ago there's a whole bunch of stuff
on there who decides what's on there and
what i see when i first go on there uh
you do right so um we have a
chronological feed right and and you
decide who you're following who you're
blocking who you're moving all the way i
just started an account and i'm not
following anyone and there's a news feed
so we want to inject you with some
content so you automatically follow like
our main gab account and like our
support account and i think my account
as well and that's that's to you know
because we want the fee to have some
stuff in there when you first start
we're working on that so we're uh
working on the onboarding process where
we're going to recommend you join
certain groups and things like that but
once once you're in there you can
unfollow those if you want and file
whoever you want block wherever you want
but that's how it works it's a
chronological feed there actually is no
algorithm in that feed yeah as soon as i
signed up i was following three people
gab
your account and then there's this
pharmaceutical salesman
his name's
donald trump okay i'm also following
i'm also following him automatically uh
you can unfollow them if you want you
can can i ask you why are we
automatically following donald j trump
we just wanted content in the feed and a
lot of people are coming there because
they know that we have all this content
mirrored there that's all that is but
you can make the choice if you want to
opt out of that you can why don't you
just didn't want to blank feed right do
you mirror joe biden uh i don't think so
no
we could yeah well we could sure uh
because you know one of the one one of
the big mirroring it's actually me
manually posting his statements as he
sends them out well there you go uh one
of the one of the big criticisms that
twitter got was when they were in this
congressional hearing a republican
pointed out that when any person in dc
signs up they're defaulted to democrats
to follow right right so if gaba is just
doing trump
no i understand that trump i understand
that yeah absolutely yeah we want to
work on the onboarding process to allow
people to shape their entire experience
so we just came up with this new feature
called feeds and it's going to allow you
to create your own algorithm actually so
you you can sit down you can say i want
to see a feed that shows these 50 people
and these five groups that are on gab
that's one of the features that we have
as groups
and i want it to be sorted by top
content from all those people and all
those groups and this hashtag and this
rss feed from the past 24 hours and that
is my you know top 20 i don't know my 24
hour top post political news feed right
and people could subscribe to that
algorithm other people can subscribe you
could share that publicly that feed can
be viewed by people who aren't members
of gab so that is the big thing that
we're going towards now is just total
customization allowing you to create and
shape your own experience versus us
doing it for you i feel like if we
federated networks it would be the first
time in human history that two giant
social networks have federated
you said that you you experimented with
the federalists you whipped up mastodon
code
create gap basically so explain you guys
used to have proprietary software then
something happened and then now you're
open source code and and then you said
you have problems with the photoverse
can you talk about them yeah so gab is
open source you know unlike getter
unlike rumble and like all these other
alternatives our code is actually open
source so if you're an engineer you can
go and look at the code right now at
code.gab.com
so you don't have to believe what i'm
saying when i say we're not censoring
you can actually go in and see how our
moderation system works and all of that
stuff which you know facebook can't say
that none of these other alternatives
can say that i think with the exception
of mine which is also open source which
is great i mean that's fantastic
and we experimented with the the
fetiverse and what we found is that it
just does not work at scale we were
getting attacked from all these
different servers that were
really just bots you know we're talking
about bot activity right and whatever we
did we just could not stop it was
bogging down all of our infrastructure
it's like a ddos attack from the
fetiverse coming at us right so we
disabled the fedover stuff and just kept
using the backbone of the open source uh
software and i've built up from there
when you were proprietary in the
beginning what happened why did you
decide to change and open well you know
we wanted to work smart and not hard um
and the mastodon open source code base
uh allowed a richer feature set that we
didn't have we didn't have you know the
team at the time to build out all these
different features and all these ideas
that we wanted to do so we said you know
we're going to take this to the next
level and go open source with everything
and go into the fetaverse and we gave
the fetavers a real shot but it just
didn't work at our scale like we were
too big gab itself at the time was
bigger than the entire fetiverse
combined now forget it it's like you
know 20 times bigger than the entire
fetavers combined so i pulled up your
terms of service as we've done with the
past ceo sure sure and uh i got to say
some of this stuff is protected by the
first amendment and sure you do ban it
well you know the founding fathers
didn't have things like doxing they
didn't have things like uh spam internet
spam um you know pornography is
protected by the first amendment
technically but i would i would say that
the founding fathers would be uh
appalled that is protected and that
scotus ruled that because the founding
fathers believed that our our country
and our rights and our liberties belong
to a morally righteous people um and i
don't think that they would they would
defend that and secondly but that's an
opinion it is it's my opinion sure so
you know i do think it's fair to point
out because we do have people asking
about porn sure personally i understand
why you're like look you know this is
not something on our platform because
it's it's very different from an
expression platform conversations
arguments debates ideas but maybe the
appropriate way to deal with it would be
a filter as opposed to saying even
though it is protected i don't think
it's right well the problem is that
people don't use the filter and then
bots come on and spam the heck out of
every comment section every top post
every reply with porn are people gonna
use a site like that is pork being
censored right now on the internet you
can go on twitter you can go on twitter
and your replies right now and probably
find some porn right now i think doesn't
the google play store ban it technically
i believe so but twitter allows it right
it's funny the other thing too is i i
love people that that claim that it's
speech right um the way to test this is
go out to your town square right and and
start preaching the word of god and
you'll be fine uh stump for a political
candidate you'll be fine
try filming porn in the town square
right is that speech is that protected
are you going to land up in jail it is
porn is actually an interesting one
because i don't think it's as easy to
say that it is protected it is protected
but there's interesting questions about
it because we still
i would i'm pretty sure every single
person like well maybe 90. people in
this country if you went around naked
they would be upset with you for it
right so so it's interesting not in san
francisco
yeah and and you know that that's true
too but but but it's interesting i would
say
while
my view of it is you're expressing your
opinion on you know adult content
it's it's it's degrees of everything you
know some people claim to be libertarian
but still believe in borders some people
say you're a real libertarian because
you you there should be no borders and
they're both arguing they're
libertarians i think it's fair to say
that on a scale of one to a hundred you
guys are 99 free speech sure there may
be an argument about what is first
amendment well we're 100 political
speech
right maybe we're 99 free expression
yeah this is the first time i've ever
thought of imagery not as a form of
speech putting a picture up is very
different than expressing your opinions
sure absolutely
it doesn't have it also does it pass the
miller test i mean the the the the
supreme court gives us the miller test
for you know deciding what obscenity is
does it have artistic value does it have
scientific value and i would argue that
you know the porn that we're seeing is
not artistic it doesn't it's not
scientific you know these things these
things are uh you know in the hands of
10 year olds right now some of it is but
it's like 1 out of 50. so i just also
have a question just really quick who
decides what's uh obscene who decides
what spam can you walk us through the
process of what's happening here and how
do we know that the system won't be
abused so there's also some some like uh
internet pro you know content creators
that that you know have their bosoms out
is that something that gets banned um
and
where's the oversight when it comes to
getting rid of you know banning people
and censoring people yeah so if you look
at our terms of services it actually
says if it has artistic or medical value
then it's not going gonna be considered
obscene um ultimately at the end of the
day you know human beings have to make
these decisions right and they're hard i
mean even the supreme court when they
were pressed with this same exact topic
you know uh justice potter stewart i
believe said you know it when you see it
right that was the supreme court's
official response to this right so this
ultimately at the end of the day is
decided by real human beings um and you
know are we going to make mistakes is
there going to be false positives
absolutely but we do our best every day
and likewise you know the big thing that
makes us different is that 98 of the
moderation on the site is done by the
site's users itself so we have these
group systems right you can create a
group and the users create those groups
and they moderate those groups so
they're deciding is this obscene for my
group or is it not you know most of the
time we're not dealing with that stuff
that users are dealing with it before it
even gets to us where our team comes in
is with illegal activity and that is
where you know we will actually take
action if you know people are
you know posting child pornography for
example
we have to legally report that and
morally report that to law enforcement
and get it off the site immediately
that's the type of stuff where we take
action this other stuff this day-to-day
type stuff on individual use case stuff
we leave that up to our users if you
don't like what someone's saying if it
offends you unfollow them block them
you're an adult right several people are
saying that porn actually is not
protected speech
it's not speech first of all it's not
but it's not i don't think it's protect
it's protected under i don't think it is
either i think it's the law is just not
being enforced i think that the
pornography that we see on the internet
today would absolutely fail the miller
test and it's detestable that our
society is not doing something about it
what about you thoughts
out wait what he thought
because there's women they're not nude
right like if you go to twitch right
there's a lot of women gaming the system
that way right they're just like showing
their cleavage or whatever yeah yeah i
mean i'm just asking because this is a
question
that's not pornographic no okay so
that's allowed on the cabinet so i want
to point out in the content standard
section it is
unique in that when we had rumble on
i believe we were looking at the wrong
terms but their terms were very similar
to what we see in silicon valley sure uh
getters same thing no hateful you know
content or whatever uh your guys contact
sanders uh
gab's content standard specifically says
that uh if it's protected political
religious symbolic or commercial speech
under the first amendment the
constitution it will be allowed on the
website
but then it also says there are some
exceptions um it can't be unlawful we
get you can unlawfully threaten of
course it's not protected imminent
incitement not protected interfere with
the operation of a computer of course
that's not not not protected being
obscene explicit pornographic i think
we've just discussed that infringing on
someone's patent trademark trade secret
copyright is a is a civil tort i believe
but not protected you get sued for that
penalties violate the legal rights of
another uh we understand impersonating
someone now is that protected speech if
you dressed up like donald trump and
went out in the street and told people
you were him see that's a parody though
right it's protected no no no no no no i
mean like if someone literally pretended
like you ever see that video where the
guy pretends to be joel osteen
and he actually sneaks in
he's walking around and everyone's
shaking his hand because he looks like
him i'm wondering if that wouldn't be
fraud because you're not taking someone
from something from someone it's
malicious it depends on the intent right
is it malicious intent is someone
pretending to be donald trump and raise
money you know under under his name
right that it really depends on intent
and our policy with that is if oh it
literally says yes it's not protected by
the first amendment correct yes oh well
there you go and you've got uh
commercial activities related to finance
which is also a legal barrier yeah fraud
type stuff yep and and also people need
to realize this too you you can't even
promote some financial services legally
so it's not protected correct uh give
the impression they emanate from or
endorsed by you that i understand right
uh we got to protect our brand yeah that
would be
i guess if someone says civil tort in
the same sense yeah andrew torba
promotes this site or something right
when i didn't and linking to any content
of the above categories i mean
it seems like for the most part you're
basically just outlining what already is
not protected by the first amendment
correct yeah exactly and we're the only
you know aside from mines i haven't seen
their toss in a while it's super simple
but just really good when you said that
in moderation there's sometimes mistakes
made is there any mistake that you could
tell us that you guys are reversed that
was a problem from your moderation team
that you guys knew you guys made a
mistake on and fixed yeah yeah so there
was uh a post actually from chris langan
who is the highest iq person in the
world who is on gab and uh one uh one of
our moderation moderators uh i you know
removed one of his posts and we had
reviewed that it was escalated to our
team and to our legal team and our legal
team is filled with first amendment
lawyers who know this stuff inside and
out they helped us write this right
they've been with us for many years and
we reviewed that and we uh turned over
that decision so when you know again
it's human beings we're human beings so
when we make a mistake we will fix it
and we will undo that and i apologize to
the community it's very rare that that
happens but that happened a few months
ago and i personally apologize to chris
for that and we undid it yeah redemption
i think is also very important and
that's why some people we were asking uh
the person yesterday is there a
possibility for the people who were
censored a possibility of redemption or
a bit an ability to come back is that
something also possible on gap that is
actually in our terms of service where
we say if you take this to a competent
court and you believe that this was
protected by the first amendment then we
will reinstate you and i think we're
that's unique i don't think we're the
only ones that have that what if someone
gets banned with an account for
violating it and then they spin up a new
account
i mean it's really difficult for us to
know that it's gonna be them but
honestly if they are as long as they're
gonna learn their lesson and and not you
know do whatever they did again i'm okay
with them starting fresh i don't think
that's a problem ian talks about this i
think it's a good idea too he says ban
the account not the person correct no so
when we're moderating too you know our
moderation focuses on the individual
post i think it's absurd that we you
know ban an entire account for one post
a lot of times people have a bad day
right and they posted something that
maybe they shouldn't have they were
threatening someone or something they're
taking their rage out on somebody on the
internet right
is it surprising at all that these uh
authoritarian despotic big tech
companies would give you a life sentence
for one infraction right and and no
appeal and no redemption and you know as
a christian that is that is a whole part
of christianity is redemption right um
and and that is something that i i
definitely believe in and i think that
you know when we're moderating again
it's it's at the individual post level
you know and also are we seeing a
behavior right so if someone has been
doing this now if they've been making
threats of violence and citing violence
for you know six months well at a
certain point we have to take additional
steps right and even then we we give
them the benefit of the dial we try to
talk with them we give them warnings and
stuff but at a certain point if they're
sitting there and they're you know
threatening people all day long and
they've been warned you know a dozen
times for months over a period of months
at a certain time we have to take
additional action right to make a point
known otherwise you know you know
they're going to run they're going to
run wild
i got mine's this kind of policy and um
it's it's similar it doesn't outline it
the same way that you guys do but it's
very similar uh it has to be to get
banned it has to be illegal content um
malware token manipulation impersonation
i definitely think mines needs to
clarify what impersonation is because
parity is allowed right yes but for the
most part this is interesting too uh
minds has two different categories for
strikes one is if you're posting gore or
porn you have to flag it as not safe for
work by yourself otherwise your whole
channel will be flagged permanently as
not safe for work yeah i did that i
think that was one of my ideas that's a
good idea that was that was a group of
us came up with that idea yeah and then
harassment and spam you'll get banned
for but that specifically says
spam is repeated unwanted and or
unsolicited actions automated or manual
negatively impacting groups
spam is spam we get that
uh mines has pretty lacks rules for the
most part but the the interesting thing
is the jury system and then they show
you actions taken that's pretty cool so
yeah yeah yeah you know it's got a lot
of potential no hate you did you control
f hate let's uh say about hate speech
absolutely i hate that word that's why i
think you wrapped it up the word hate
does not appear on my side what i don't
like is the ability to ban anyone at any
time that every lawyer is like you got
to put that in there just do it and like
no but it's like i can't say no it
wasn't my company well do you guys say
that you reserve the right to ban anyone
not sure if we have that in there or not
i don't know i don't know what you would
we will ban this but not limited to and
then it gives you a list you're like
what does that mean not limited to does
that mean you can ban anything right
well legally yes
i don't know
i'd have to read through it all the way
through most companies just include it
because you could be sued if you don't
right and you could and it could be a
ridiculous claim right but maybe it's
the right thing to do to be like as you
enter into this contract to produce a
contract to produce content on this
platform
you know we as a company as you know
company recognize it'll be generating
revenue for us to the work you do and
thus you have certain rights on the
platform
i think that the network should be able
to ban anyone at any time personally but
that that's why i'm into the federated
process and decentralization of content
and and um
i guess you would call it like services
decentralized services so like no
centralized login the data data's not
held on one server where the king can
shut it all down tomorrow um
but i do but i think the king should be
able to shut his server down his his
node and block out anyone from his node
i just that's why i'm aiming towards
like individual liberty on a
decentralized mass scale kind of like
the united states where you have
sovereignty of your household so we kind
of do that with groups right now right
so they have full control over who gets
to join the group who gets to post in
the group what's allowed in the group we
don't control any of that they set the
rules if they run a cat's group which
there is a cats group on on gab and
someone is posting dogs in there
right how dare they the ultimate sin
[Laughter]
you know well obviously they're going to
remove that and they're probably going
to kick that person from the group but
it doesn't mean that the person is
kicked off of gab they're just going to
have to go post in you know the dog
group i would do that
i don't i'm not i don't like cats but uh
just another thing is that i really
wanted to ask you are you guys making
any moves to prevent an echo chamber on
your platform because some people are
saying it's only with this particular
viewpoint on your platform that
dominates are there any efforts by you
guys to try to reach out to other people
to bring them on to kind of broaden the
perspective and conversation well this
is happening naturally right now and
actually there have been academic
studies on this that show that gab is
not an echo chamber specifically because
we are not censoring based on arbitrary
political viewpoints we have a
chronological feed and we allow people
to shape and create their own experience
so they're exposed to a lot of different
things that um you know they might not
see on other platforms um you know what
we're also seeing is this as i said this
is happening naturally so you know
people who are you know not wanting to
get vaccinated right are coming over to
gab we're seeing medical doctors and
stuff and it's not even political at all
by the way we have tens of thousands of
groups that have nothing to do with
politics you know there's people that
come on gap to post about classic cars
which is one of my favorite groups
there's people that come on gab to talk
about arts and crafts and and
homeschooling and and faith and all
these different topics that are are
talked about and and these niche
communities that are forming through our
group system so you know there's
anything but an echo chamber the
experience is what you make of it if you
want to create an echo chamber on gab
with your account you can do that but if
you want to you know be exposed to a lot
of different ideas you can also do that
too so we want to leave it in your hands
i got to know about this
i want to touch on the center it's a
browser that you guys built and it's uh
it's a fork of the brave browser um and
basically what i got from it i've only
used it once and i remember i went to a
website and i believe it was made so
that you could comment on websites maybe
you were banned from right so like if
nick fuentes or anybody want to go to
twitter and comment on the twitter post
they could comment in the center browser
so anyone else is amazing yeah so this
is this is gab trends which you have
right here so anybody can go to
trends.gab.com enter in any url of any
news article and leave a comment on it
and the the news article uh the the news
outlet can do nothing to stop you is
this the center is that the center that
is part of the center yes so the browser
itself has this baked in as an extension
and unfortunately we've had to
depreciate the center because we didn't
have the resources or the time to upkeep
it but i think we're going to bring it
back in the future i think i think
that's a great idea
even with vetiver software that could be
our main browser function to be able to
comment on other places you go it's epic
it's like putting an entire layer on top
of the internet that the other sites
can't do anything why couldn't you guys
maintain it whatever well it's it's
maintaining a browser is a lot of work
yeah it's a lot of work but
what about just the extension uh the
extension yes so it lives now well the
extension the problem with the extension
is the extension got banned just like
everything else from the extension app
stores on google and firefox so that's
why we needed our own browser in the
first place and the browser is very
difficult to maintain so this concept
this idea lives on on capture is it
proprietary i couldn't find the code uh
this is yeah the the
no i think we open-sourced the extension
yeah you can open it we'll start working
on it really yeah uh the the browser i
believe is open i think we have a repo
for that yeah the extension i think is
as well but trends isn't this is this is
proprietary i remember a few years ago
media organizations used to have
comments on almost every single news
story and you were able to get in there
get people's perspective gets people get
people's thoughts and then slowly and
surely every media organization just
stopped it yep
internet theory bro yeah and then
everybody moved to the to you know
twitter and everything else and they
shut that down yeah and it was so
disappointing and slowly and surely now
we're in this kind of place where they
only have the algorithm of what they
want you to see correct so i appreciate
you know the effort to fight against
everyone stopping you everyone's
standing in your way and i think we
definitely need more of things like the
center where voices of people could
still come back what do you think people
watching would do if they realized we
were all ai generated you know there's
no real show here it's just like some
fat guy in a room with a cousin i'm a
real i'm a real human being six percent
of them would keep watching and not even
bad knives yeah they'd be like well
whatever it's funny i believe everything
at face value no we're real human beings
unfortunately i think so ian ian no
that's what makes this different than
you know the regime is you know their
vision is for transhumanism so they want
to ascend humanity they want to ascend
beyond humanity and become gods and they
want the rest of us plugged into the
maida verse where they control and
dominate us for all eternity that is
their vision vision for the future when
are you gonna make your own metaverse uh
you're building everything else yeah i i
don't know how i feel about the
metaverse you know i i wrote a blog post
about this and you know from the
christian point of view and i feel like
we're going to need christian
missionaries to go into the metaverse
to pull people out back to reality right
digital heroine dentist yes literally
you should you should make a a virtual
world app where it's like the gab
metaverse and everyone's a frog a person
and just be like this is our version of
reality you know if we could layer
dissenter into the metaverse experience
you could have like a meta layer or a
resistance bro yeah that's a good so the
challenge is you know they they nuke you
they ban you but when people are in that
metaverse
there's a reason why they got rid of
comments there's a reason why disenter
was so dangerous right if you could get
a message layer to people who are in the
system that gives them a it's like a
communication
it's like in the matrix when they call
the operator in the ship that's what it
would be like someone on the outside
telling you what's going on right right
wow she can't allow that man
yeah i think they just went for that i
gotta manage there's something exciting
about the metaverse happening it's
because we can be like in the and we can
be
you know the heroes fighting to put to
free people which i guess we're kind of
doing i like the idea of being able to
do like 80 calculations at once and like
play 90 games at once because it's going
to help us evolve the way our minds
think when we're controlling computers
with our brains without the finger
interface that's cool the the computer
is going to be controlling you right
is it all right it might already be
controlling i'm here on a tv show you
know it's like controlling me to be here
yep yeah we could be we could be
controlled by the ai and all that stuff
already and that we are well we are
through through the feeds that's what
they're doing and facebook has admitted
to this by the way they've been admitted
to socially engineering user base
absolutely we talk about this on the
show yeah yeah this is happening right
now you open up your facebook and you
scroll your feed and you are being
socially engineered whether you realize
it or not dude oh even the frequency
that the the tv is blaring at you
correct that's got to be brainwashing
and the hurts of music as well the
reason they that what do you think they
call it tv programming they are
programming your mind the same thing
happening with the feeds as well that's
not why they i like the meme but it is
but it's it's called that because it was
like a program i don't i don't know much
initially history yeah yeah tv history
was basically just like the program
didn't mean like they were programming
like a computer because right you know
computers weren't prominent enough it
was literally just like the list of
shows they had it fits before that they
had television
they would send you a telegram then they
had a
program the word's probably been around
longer so if i could ask you just
getting back on course here what's
stopping you guys from growing and
expanding where do you guys want to go
and what's standing in your way from
achieving that
so i you know i think our mission right
now is to protect and preserve free
speech on the internet and to survive
that's it survive and thrive gab is
inevitable as long as we can continue to
exist it's inevitable that people will
you know go to these other platforms and
find out the hard way that it's not what
it's you know being sold out to be and
then they inevitably come over to gab so
we see things like getter pop up like
when parlor popped up we saw a huge
amount of growth and then they got taken
out because they're hosted on amazon
servers and they're dependent on app
stores and that is when we got a huge
surge the same thing is going to happen
with all these other guys they think
that if they ban hate speech and they
bend the knee and they ban political
dissidents like nick fuentes that you
know apple and google are going to be
benevolent to them and they're going to
let them exist but what they don't
realize is that they're a sil they're
built on silicon valley infrastructure
and trying to take on silicon valley
okay you cannot take on silicon valley
built on silicon valley infrastructure
it is a matter of time the second that
getter or truth social or whoever it is
gets big enough they're going to pull
the rug out and their excuse could be
whatever it could be medical
misinformation it could be election
misinformation it could be protecting
our democracy right take your pick they
can ban you for no reason because bezos
wakes up and decides i don't want to
post parlor anymore one click goodbye
that's what happened to parlor that's
what happened to us and that's why we
built our own infrastructure didn't they
go through your domain everything yes
domain go daddy bandus yes and thanks to
epic.comik.com
who is our domain registrar the free
speech domain registrar that is what
allows us to to have a domain registrar
there was a there are these really angry
people they're mad that dan bongino uses
all like i guess what you'd call right
wing infrastructure which is a real
weird way to frame it let's just call it
resistance
uh mass formation rebellion
infrastructure and they can't shut them
down because they contact their friends
in silicon valley and they just say
sorry they're not using infrastructure
what well it's i mean as far as i know
rumble and some of these other things
are you talking about his show is that
something some i was reading that there
was a complaint from one of these
lefting publications that because he
uses
you know infrastructure outside of
silicon valley they can't get him banned
that's that's the only way to do it
that's the only way to do it i mean you
cannot be built on this infrastructure
and then go out there and say we're
going to take down jason we're going to
go out there and take down big tech and
meanwhile our servers are hosted by
amazon guys i think of it as a blob like
the big tech is a blob and then if
you're trying to build a blob to
counteract the blob the blob will
consume you and become a larger blob
right you got to get outside the second
that you become a threat to their
hegemony they will take you out with one
click and it's over so to the content
creators out there who are saying well
why should i join ghetto or why should i
join gab it's real simple you know
you're investing in a big tech owned and
controlled infrastructure or are you
investing in an infrastructure that is
wholly owned by gab gab that is attacked
and de-platformed more than any of these
other players in the space and has not
only survived it but has thrived through
it and has become more resilient the
most resilient platform on the internet
today to defend free speech
period has parallel economies has tim
talked to you about the charity we
started calling an open network
foundation we're building like a
fetiverse package that's able to be
federated i'm fascinated with federating
networks yes and what i'd like to do is
basically you download an application
you you run it you install it and then
you can start uploading videos to a
server of your choice rumble personal
server well the the the idea is
so that someone could have their own
version of patreon facebook or whatever
right right so you get your own server
space you download the package we're
gonna make it we're gonna give it away
for free you install it you tell people
hey go to my website it's you know
timcast.com and when they go there they
see a social media feed it's connected
to the network of all the other websites
that use that service but it's all
hosted by you it means you got to pay
for it but you also have the option to
plug in and have people pay memberships
right just like any other subscription
service and then if i go on ian's
website
i can go to the search and i can type in
like you know i'm looking for a person
and i can find my website and you can
follow it yes it's federated right so
dab and then i can go to view his gab
feed on my application and you can still
get log the views and the activity right
you're making me think read-only is the
way to go because i don't want to get
hit with spam comments yes yes um maybe
there's a there's a way to do like an
amalgamated read-only with some limited
outgoing function from that but it could
just be a read-only package at that
right right so first of all i love that
you guys are building right you're not
just complaining about the problem
you're out there building which is what
i've been doing for five and a half
years um and i think this is speaking to
something i've also been talking about
which is the balkanization of social
media and the fragmentation of social
media so we saw the consolidation where
facebook's buying up instagram and
whatsapp and all the players in the
space that is over there is no control
there's nothing more to consolidate so
now it's fragmenting and it's
balkanizing into communities that share
values and our little community on the
internet is going to be the community
that defends first amendment protected
speech at all costs
you know i would say i think it is still
what was the word you use balkanizing
and then the other word of it coming
together like fragmentation yeah or
consolidation consolidation microsoft
bought blizzard right a couple days ago
68 billion dollars the largest billion
dollars 68 billion 68.7 the largest
corporate cut consummation i've ever
seen in my life that i know of like like
uh entertainment corporate consolidation
so i think they're gonna start going
after the movie industry they're gonna
buy paramount they're gonna buy
microsoft might end up doing it and try
and consolidate all the video game in
industry and all the movie industry and
then create the metaverse of the movie
tv video game experience where you're
the main character it's a different
movie every time you play you see
facebook going all in on this you see
microsoft going on in this you see
disney is also going all in on the
mataverse um i want no part of it i want
to live in the real world i want to
empower people what we're building is
about empowering people to speak freely
and to get access to information that
they can't get anywhere else and after
that i want them to go out and live
their lives with their families i don't
care if they're sitting on my website
all day i don't want them sitting on my
website all day i want to empower them
to speak their mind freely to other
people and to communicate with other
people and get access to information
that's my mission it's going to be
the year 2273
a hovercraft is going to pull a guide of
a matrix pod and he's going to be like
why do my eyes hurt and then you know
someone's going to go because you've
never used them and then they're going
to go in the ship and then be going
through the tunnels and then the door is
going to open up and there's going to be
these crazy underground buildings and
then he's going to be the guy's going to
be like where are we this is gab the
last free city on earth you know where
the person is are going to part of the
pod well you know it's fine
you're still alive because they kept you
alive in that pod for 200 years just
like neo in the matrix i will not live
in the pod and it's funny you bring up
gab cities because this is a concept i
just talked about um you know i i think
that this is a very real possibility
that we could see gabbers start to form
their own cities you know maybe what's
stopping a gabber from buying some land
out in montana or wyoming and creating a
gab city we're actually we're well we're
starting with free damastan have you
heard of it no no it's not it's actually
just a very big acreage property we're
gonna be building on we'll be putting
the show there but we're gonna be
expanding and setting up a bunch of
different stuff there but one of the
things we discussed was setting up uh
production facilities in an old
kind of dying town in west virginia
where they have they'll have like 15
buildings in a small area that used to
be a small town and people are moving
out the buildings are falling apart so
we come in we buy one we fix one up we
expand and eventually it's like
a city of people who share values and
are working towards these similar goals
right so it would be like a production
city it would be like a podcast town you
can create an entire parallel economy in
that town i mean this is a concept that
i've been talking about for make luke
bucks oh yeah made of gold foil nice you
can eat them
bullets
i want edible currency ian ends up
creating his own federal reserve yeah
his own local freedom stand reserve and
controls all currency and he's rich well
it would be like in an account that i
wouldn't have access to and it would
just slowly give out tokens to people
that utilize the system kind of like a
reward setup right maybe that's a that's
a that's a very early way to look at it
you have to barter and buy everything
with bullets that's okay
that should be the current we actually
we talked about we were talking about
that as a joke that like a guy walks
into the store and he's like you know
i'll get a roast beef on rye with swiss
uh okay that'll be uh 150 bmg and two
seven six twos uh do you have change for
250 bmg yeah we do and the paul some
nine millimeter we should
do that
i have one more question that i'm really
curious about you only get to pick one
ron paul ron desantis donald trump
ron paul
okay wow
yeah
yeah but come on man nobody nobody if i
only had to pick one yeah ron paul is is
of course like there's no question well
you never know you know some people have
a difference you know you get the trump
people and they're like trump of course
exactly
what did ron paul say on his way out
that they were psychopathic
authoritarian something that was like a
den of vipers his last speech was
absolutely brilliant on the house floor
and definitely be watched uh they called
him dr no and he absolutely did uh
a lot of not governing which was awesome
we got to get ron on rogan and get him
hooked up with these doctors to get the
life extension like david sinclair to
harvard i want ron to be around for
their families
ron do it you got to make the sacrifice
not about what you want he takes some
nad he looks 10 years younger so
i i like rand paul he's cool too but how
come rand isn't as cool as ron paul dude
ron paul it's ron paul i mean i know
right why why father of our nation i
don't know listen anybody that wants to
say end the fed or odd at the fed is
going to get my vote right
does rand advocate for that stuff i'm
not sure he he does for the audit he
yeah he proposed a couple bills in the
senate saying we need to audit the
federal reserve uh bernie sanders
supported it initially and then dropped
off last minute there was a chance that
it was going to pass in the house um and
in the senate and then last minute like
major players just fell out man that's
i like rand paul man he stands up for
what he believes and he pushes back you
know we're lucky to have him ron was a
legend though uh it's it's too bad
bernie caved you know he was supposed to
be the populist insurgent for the left
and he didn't do it he like got halfway
there and was like i guess i'll just
lick hillary's boots
and then he did so weird yeah it was
very where the the bird landed on his
podium and like that's not a coincidence
that's magnetic man birds attuned to
magnetic they felt his energy
he should have been pres i i was so into
that why did he cave
obviously it's conspiracy town now but
like you think he got threatened no i
think he got a million dollars from his
book
i think you know when he started his
campaign he wasn't expecting it to get
as big as it did he started making money
and i tell you this people some people
when they make money they start they get
that whisper in their ear from that
devil on their shoulders saying you
deserve it it's yours these people are
too stupid they don't deserve it and
bernie's like yeah you're right i [ __ ]
my whole life for this i deserve four
houses or how many houses does he have
he has three houses let's find out
my opinion of him is that as he started
getting more and more famous
he started getting people whispering in
his ears and he was like i've dealt with
this yeah no i've dealt with this i've
had people come to me with large sums of
money large offers what they found out
is that i'm not doing this for money
it's not about money and i can't be
bought number one then they tried to use
fear and what they found out is that i
only fear god i don't fear them and now
at this point you know their only thing
left at this point is to continue with
the smears or to just pretend i don't
exist right so that's why you're not
going to see me on you know fox news or
any of the major players um is because
they don't want to give me the air time
to to speak my mind to talk about these
things when you say you're not doing it
for the money i believe you dude and
it's not about you i can't trust you i
believe you because you freed the
software code of gab right right ian he
finally got what he wanted us a taxi i
was like i freed the code in it was
mind-blowing tim was telling me that you
guys started using the mastodon code in
like february of 2020 or something it
was just it was july 2019 yeah that was
such a good move it was a big move it's
bigger than us it was a hard move man it
was it was definitely a hard move um and
you know it's something that you know
facebook can you see facebook's code no
it's so awesome right like come on
you have no idea how their algorithms
work there's probably like oh there's
probably some real good stuff in there
yeah people don't realize they think
it's really simple like a a box appears
and says here's a picture of a dog it
could actually have things in it like
person iq level deemed 70 [ __ ] feed
them trash and you'd be like that's what
they're saying about me yeah you they
were experimenting on people well this
is the thing that i don't like about you
know getter and stuff too is if you look
at their code if you look at you know
the website they actually have facebook
and google pixels that are tracking you
so you're literally you know you think
you're i'm leaving facebook i'm going
over to this alternative and like you're
still being tracked by facebook over
there yeah if you have google ads on
your website you're getting tracked by
google all your users are getting
tracked by google do you know how hard
it was for us to build and maintain gab
without using things like google
analytics because we didn't want our
users tracked by google so we had to
build all of that stuff and they make
this stuff free on purpose so they can
get the data we didn't want to give
google or facebook or anything we didn't
care if it was free we didn't care if it
made our lives easier we didn't care if
it made our road harder and we had to go
build our own google analytics and all
this stuff we did it and we're you can
actually verify this yourself and go and
look now hold on a minute um
facebook knows when you poop and that's
a very important bit of data for their
for their operations so you're saying
that gab doesn't know when it's users
are going to the bathroom we track the
least amount of data
possible so we require like an email to
sign up you can actually look at this if
you have ad blockers and stuff you'll
see there's there's nothing on the site
right so we don't care about that stuff
what we care is about empowering people
to speak freely we don't care about
tracking their every click and every
move
well how about we go to super chats my
friends if you have not already get
those super chat questions in smash the
like button subscribe to the channel
share this show with all of your friends
it really helps because we don't have a
marketing budget we just rely on word of
mouth but don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member and around 11 or so p.m
we will have a members only uncensored
not family-friendly version of the show
available for all of you so let's read
what people have to say
the first one we have is thank god for
gab and there is a fist and a smiley
face well all right there you go then we
got a nice 100 super chat appreciate
that so people are really getting uh
excited shout out to mastodon too for
laying the groundwork
absolutely as much as much as they're
not happy no they they hate us yeah but
that's what open source code is about
wasn't it weird though i remember
the point of open source code was to
empower everyone and then when they
actually empowered you they're like no
wait not you yes exactly that's the
weirdest thing for me because
you know i used to hang out in hacker
community bat way back then especially
during occupy and all of those people
were like everyone should have the
ability to speak and then and they they
were all about free speech for everyone
all of a sudden these same people are
now like no we've changed our mind we
don't want free speech but we're going
to make free speech software what
happened to you dudes people lost their
minds there there were a bunch of i'll
tell you this man they were all lefty a
bunch of my hacker friends lefties you
know with anonymous and these other
groups that were fighting and protesting
and then in uh you know 2017 2018 2019
with all the trump stuff happening i see
a lot of people just toeing the line
but a few people i know who are still
lefty
were just like overtly screw them i'm
not changing my positions and now
they're being called right wing it's
it's but it's obvious it happens all of
us all right rws says thank you for
guests without handlers
all right there you go
greg herbold says tim i have a
seven-year-old godson that can't stop
talking about skateboarding do you have
a suggestion for a brand that would be a
good starter board for him love the work
all of you guys do
starter board uh i don't know i ride
eight and a half by thirty two and i
like using uh anti here as my favorite
brand but i i don't know if they still
have the termite boards that you know
for a seven year old they're a lot
smaller
but maybe maybe he's just gonna have to
start riding a regular board i i guess
if you're not gonna go with any like
smaller size boards you can try and find
a 7.5 i like anti-hero i don't know if
anti-hero makes 7.5 because they're like
pool boards but uh that are real
uh r-e-a-l skateboards that's the name
of the company those are my favorites it
looks like bernie has three houses i was
an element guy myself element yeah
element's pretty good actually
surprisingly a lot of people thought it
was corporate but they're pretty good my
issue was that i was broken i found him
to be brittle yeah
so i only had a couple and i did a
kickflip off a gap and cracked it and
and i hear oh man never done me wrong
but i ride big boards for someone who
doesn't skate vert it's kind of funny or
for or transition for the most part
all right let's see we got
let's try and find some good questions
because a lot of ones that are you know
kind of dumb as as it can be i have a
question free men die free says it isn't
right versus left it's libertarian
versus authoritarian the truth is a
libertarian bias free markets private
property individual liberty yes because
in order to maintain authoritarian
systems you have to lie to people so
that's really what it is the people who
believe the truth are people who are
free and the people who believe the lies
are being enslaved i would say it's not
even authoritarian versus libertarian
it's more that authoritarians and
libertarians are living together and we
have to figure out how to live together
that mind those mindsets exist and there
will always exist it's two sides of a
coin
all right chris keeper says andrew i'm a
software engineer are you hiring do you
accept free labor how can i help i love
what you are doing tim keep up the
fantastic work thanks uh we're not
hiring at the moment we just fired a
bunch of people but i'm sure we'll be
hiring later this year so reach out to
me on gab can people work on the source
code from the distance uh they can but
we don't make that easy right now just
because it complicates and distracts our
processes so
we don't really do that too much but
it is possible i mean they could
download the source and play around with
it sure all right
micah says have you read the book
confessions of an economic hitman it
details moderate modern american
imperialism through in issuance of loans
written by john perkins amazing book i
read that book in high school and it
totally gave me perspective how the
intelligence agencies work behind the
scenes for the greater benefit of the
corporations that truly do run things
behind the scenes
dingus asks a question about adult
content i do feel like we we answered it
but maybe we'll just go through it just
to honor the question he says my
question for mr torba why does he have
the same position on porn as the
australian government porn in australia
is illegal and must be viewed on
international servers if it doesn't
qualify as expression can or should it
be banned by governments so i don't
think you'll ever be able to fully ban
porn but i believe that we should have
some sort of check and balance to
prevent 10 year old kids from accessing
this stuff i don't think that's
unreasonable 10 year old kids can't walk
into a porn shop in real life but they
can open up their device and you know a
lot of people say well but push it off
to the parents it's the parents fault
they should be doing better parenting i
mean most of the time those people
aren't parents right and they don't
understand the reality of parenting the
reality of parenting is that every
single one of your kids friends has
these on them 24 7 and can instantly in
a click get access to this stuff and i
don't think that's okay and it destroys
their minds it destroys their future and
destroys their potential and their
relationships and correct absolutely one
of the most destructive things out there
in system
we try to keep it family friendly yeah
so that's why i like to say adult
content but to i don't want you man i'm
a hairy beast okay thanks yeah i'm the
wild animal i'm looking at a girl but
but policy wise instead of getting into
details on what kids should be watching
specifically in terms of what that is uh
i'm i'm all about people's right to
watch and and do all that stuff but we
have regulations i'm not i'm not an
anarchist i am i am i lean very
libertarian but when it comes to kids i
get a little more like hey come on let's
have some rules let's like if you want
if you want to buy booze or something we
don't sell those to kids you don't sell
drugs to kids
adult content shouldn't be shouldn't be
available to kids it feels like the
whole sending your kids off to learn
is a new thing like the 100 couple 150
years old you send them to public school
and then they come back and they're an
adult like it was the parents job to
teach the kid for millennia for and
we're seeing a transition back to that
now yeah homeschooling is big time on
the rise and and for good reason
all right we got eliot harris says you
should have matt walsh and vosh on they
reacted to each other's videos and vosh
said matt would be interesting to talk
to
yeah i would i would love to host that
one of the challenges is that vosh is
one of the only people on the left
willing to come on and have debates and
so we've had him on how many times we've
twice right once and then he was on with
uh debating charlie kirk and so whenever
we have someone who's interested you
know we've reached out to many people on
the left and they're always like no no
no
one person said yes but then canceled on
us what about jimmy dore and matt walsh
do they know each other i don't know
they'd have something there's a lot of
crossovers there it it is they probably
agree on a lot yeah uh disagreement on
on a lot of policy stuff but the
challenge for a lot of people is if they
do their own show already asking them to
not do their show to come here is
right is a lot it's a lot plus you know
jimmy's in on the west coast i believe
but i would love to have jimmy on i'm a
big fan jimmy is fantastic
he's he's what an actual populist on the
left looks like and talks about and then
when you watch his show it's funny they
call him right wing and they smear them
and it's like maybe people who don't
like authoritarianism
whether they're right or left agree with
each other and you're the bad guys you
know what i mean so it's like jimmy can
have policies on health care i don't
agree with but we we all completely
grant the authoritarians being awful
left right libertarians have a lot in
common liberty real ones at least which
are few and far the left libertarian is
hard to find man
all right let's grab some more
let's see terry hendrick says if truth
social is federated with the rest of the
fetiverse then will gab also enable
federation again by the way everyone
should run for their own fetiverse
server run their own fetiverse server
i don't think the truth social will
federate for the same reason that we had
to turn it off is because it does not
scale at least in its current
implementation
i'd be very surprised if they did that
if they did i mean it would be very
interesting if we can figure out a way
to make federation work at scale but
just from a technical standpoint we are
the only ones on the planet who have
dealt with it at this level of scale it
just doesn't scale
this is interesting uh
white student transmission says has gab
considered chartering a credit union
so we have looked into things like
buying a bank and things like that but
what it does is it opens you up to
more government regulatory regulatory
issues and and agencies you know staring
down your back right so i'd rather
partner with the bank
than buy one at this point but a credit
union is a very interesting idea i think
we have a lot of gabbers who have
brought this up and it's certainly
interesting it's just not on our road
back right now
raymond g stanley jr says tim you may
have just killed getter how does it feel
uh not good to be completely honest i
might i might not agree with you know
the positions taken by their ceo i may
have you know called out things i
thought were were bad but i look at it
like this
if on the scale of free speech it's
negative 10 and positive 10. positive 10
is free speech well gab is clearly at 9
or 10. then you have twitter which is
like negative 7. they allow you to say a
lot of things but they control most of
what you see actually maybe negative
seven's a little harsh twitter does
allow you to say a lot of things but
they still will ban you so they're
definitely the negative category where
they're controlling your speech you're
not in the free speech area
getter is like what negative one or zero
there's they're still in that space but
it's better than twitter and so my view
is if we've gained even two points on
the scale from getter that's a good
thing
you want to solidify that position and
then in the coming months move again
one step at a time it's it's you're
never going to convince an entire system
an economy or the internet to jump from
negative seven
to free speech completely it's just too
big a leap to to make that societal
change so taking any victory you can
would be a good thing
if getter is saying we're going to allow
people to speak the same as they could
on twitter but we won't editorialize i'm
like better than twitter
would it would would we be better off
using aren't they editorializing by you
know banning people like fontes for sure
i'm just saying if they're one point
better right then everyone should go
together it's better than twitter in
reality everybody should probably go to
gab if you can you guys handle that you
know yeah three bring in a million bring
it on so i i actually you know
it it doesn't feel good a lot of people
are saying like oh you know look getter
was look made to look bad and it's like
someone someone commented saying don't
confuse perfect with good you know what
getter is doing is better than twitter
and we should be happy with that victory
and keep striving to push further and
move on but it's still built on the
infrastructure so it doesn't change the
premise if people are trying to escape
big tech big tech tyranny and they're
going to a platform that is hosted by
big tech and dependent on big tech
infrastructure and dependent on big tech
app stores and have a terms of service
that is exactly like big tech then
what's the difference
and to be to be honest you know the big
question was
why not just use gab right or minds for
that matter to be honest because mines
auto posts all my stuff like when i
tweet minds picks it up instantly and so
it's just like i have my presence there
the same it makes it a lot easier
a lot easier for me i can get up to
about five social networks but more than
that i start to get like oh what am i
even going to only post the same thing
on different networks i try to be unique
on each network like mines is my crazy
you know
man i i feel bad because a lot of people
are ragging on getter you know you
brought up why did they ban nick it was
a genuine conversation i think it had to
happen and it all you did if anything
was shine a flashlight on something so i
i i don't feel like someone
if they if they're the code's private
they can be doing all sorts of stuff to
you and you don't know someone super
chatted that uh they were shocked at how
unprepared getter was for the for the
sit down
and
i don't know if you agree luke
what your thoughts well we were getting
into it you know before the show started
and i kind of asked him you know let's
talk about uh nick you know
and
we were like this is an important
conversation let's savor for the show
and and i thought it was an important
conversation
and i i think we need to have more of
these conversations and it's the only
way to bring forward the true reality of
the situation it's tough for a ceo to
speak for a company if they're not the
founder and creator of the company like
he he got hired by the company to do the
job so he wasn't there since the
beginning he didn't he wasn't the guy
that decided on the mission statement of
what the company is going to be so like
you can represent gab a lot easier
because you created the thing right
absolutely same with bill with minds and
jack with twitter
here's here's one from
sevy rose
they say that's a lie torba gab has
never been larger than the fetiverse
yes it is absolutely in terms of posts
in terms of number of users absolutely
by orders of magnitude but what does
that mean by the fighters i guess
technically if you're in the feta verse
the federalists would always by default
be bigger than one node you know what i
mean
did i mean mastodon
i guess yeah the masted on nodes yeah if
you if you take all the users across all
of the different masses so you were the
biggest we were the biggest yeah so we
were bigger than all of them combined
and then you know we still are spamming
i guess
so a lot of people are saying uh you
know this is where at the point i was
saying porn is not protected and things
like that so
uh
green country says i'm not offended by
nudity or sex but there are some bodies
that i would rather not see unclothed if
you know what i mean
well that's one way to ex to to to point
out mine's his position is what just a
filter right it filters it out yeah if
you don't mark it as explicit when you
put it up and you keep you keep
violating that ethic code of you
upholding your end of the bargain by
making an account you keep posting stuff
that's lewd you're going to get your
entire account marked lewd so that
whenever someone goes to your page it's
going to have a big e over it and it'll
be grayed out so they're going to have
to opt in to be able to see anything on
your pitch i think i think i talked with
you about with you guys about that once
that it was like there is uh
the free and open space outside the
walls of the city and you can choose to
operate in the city walls but you abide
by the city city's rules and if you
don't want to you're free to go outside
those walls and say whatever you live in
the wilderness with the tigers yeah it's
basically it's a tough debate you know
whether it's art or self-expression but
i think it's definitely been weaponized
in extremely egregious ways but i i
think at the end of the day it it has to
be
how kids are being raised and i think
it's the parents duties to inform the
kids that this is extremely dangerous
and it will ruin their lives but man
imagine a four-year-old seeing some like
crazy that's that's just so mind-warping
it's it's a difficult conversation to
have and it's it's hard you know because
how do you balance
freedoms and expression and and the
destruction of the youth all right going
back to the uk stuff brian knowles says
boris johnson had photos leaked of
private parties almost every night for
weeks during the lockdowns everyone
started calling for his resignation
months ago lotus eaters predicted he'd
lift mandates to save his position wow
yeah that's pathetic
the conservatives in the uk were the
ones calling for lockdowns and enforcing
them yeah sad
yeah you can't trust them can you
nope
all right let's see what we got here mr
the cool says hello tim and uh and cruz
it is very cold down here in south texas
for some reason results uh texans
weren't built for this type of weather i
guess the government trying to get back
at us for going red
i i implying that they're controlling
the weather
china does that openly admittedly they
brag about it yeah they've been doing
we've been doing what silver what do
they do they do silver iodide or
something in the sky yeah silver iodide
causes light to refract i think and cool
causes the temperature to cool down
that's the impetus of the idea of it and
then it condenses
yeah i haven't looked at it and looked
too great who had a project class he
wanted to see the clouds to uh block the
sun it's not a horrible idea it's just
unknown consequences it's a horrible
idea mark jensen says ian can you please
say blob again blob
blob i think i know what you mean
alien uh aileen j says james o'keefe
says amazon canceled pre-orders of his
book just joined gab love all you guys
thanks for the open conversation and
someone else said that his book has been
indefinitely delayed on audible oh wow
that's crazy
2022 is going to be nuts it already
isn't that's for us this month has been
wacky i say the least i just came across
the numbers that first has about four
million users is that right this is from
august last august i was trying to do
the math on on if it's is that included
yeah yeah oh probably included gab yeah
it may it may have i'm not sure if
they're still including us in those
because we actually got banned from a
lot of those things too okay how many
can how many users do you guys have uh
almost six million i think now okay yeah
but i mean you don't need an account to
log in so we actually have 20 million
uniques that are just using the site as
their new source and exploring and all
that stuff so so what you could you
could have an account to follow people
but not yeah to follow or to comment or
to post but most you know the vast
majority of our traffic is just
passively you know consuming the content
or following different profile or
viewing different profiles or viewing
different links or just coming to the
home page and seeing the the content
they use it as their new source really
and you don't need an account to explore
the entire site
wyatt says jimmy door will be in
pennsylvania in february i believe maybe
maybe we should look at jimmy's schedule
and see if we can come over here yeah
rock and roll jimmy's great i went on
his show and i didn't know what to
expect because this was years ago and i
knew he was like kind of on the left and
then
we ended up just having a good
conversation about everything because i
think he's he's an honest guy and that's
all that matters we can disagree on
politics and we can disagree and then
shake hands but if we're honest about
everything that's going on it goes great
i always reference my conversation with
glenn beck we were we were discussing
pro-life versus pro-choice and we both
had a really great conversation we
laughed we shook hands and he said that
that was fantastic and i was like yeah
you know we're trying right he's like
yeah it's great and people really
appreciated the honest attempt at
understanding each other
most of what you get now is tribalism
where it's like i was mentioning
that you know when i said about carhartt
if you don't want to get vaccinated quit
the left got mad at me for that yeah
they're going to get mad at you for
anything you've said right exactly
because it makes no sense i'm like i
thought they would agree with it and
there's people that are going to love
you for anything you say too so you got
to watch out for all of it that's right
and uh that's why you got to ignore the
comments
to a certain degree don't take it
personally acknowledge them understand
them and take nothing personal
all right let's uh a lot of people
mentioning jimmy dore that'd be
fantastic we'll take a look
chris stark says lizard king boards all
the way i used to skate until i
fractured my what is it l1 l6 vertebrae
and pelvis in 27 places whoa what did
you do try to ollie like a 25 going
after the leap of faith
uh you know uh there's always the death
wish boards
from uh nene williams he usually has
he's a good size he's the master of
heelflips that yeah
makes some great spices oh yeah that's
right mean
he either sent them to us or you bought
a bunch no i bought it back in the day
yeah those are great yeah we got to
order more of that stuff but not a damn
chance spices so hot some of them are so
hot we might still have them though i
don't know like you mean spicy yeah yeah
hot spicy no no i don't think so okay no
there was like lemon herb and there was
like yeah yeah that was good stuff
i i i i've known the guy uh
i wouldn't really say we're friends or
anything but i know him from back in
chicago and he went pro and he's like a
really famous guy and i saw his
instagram because he's like one of the
most famous pro skaters and he sells
these spices so we bought them super
soup they're really good stuff the
chicken one is what we we annihilated
those the spicy chicken yeah it's so
good we put it on everything i put on
grilled cheese oh yeah yeah we i gotta i
gotta order some of that stuff cause
they're probably in a box downstairs
somewhere to be honest
all right colin pittman says just joined
gab also back in the early 2000's john
titor was on message boards talking
about a civil war where it was the rural
country versus the cities oddly similar
to today yeah but didn't he predict that
in like 2008
do you guys remember that stuff i've
heard of this guy this is the time
traveler yeah i thought he predicted
that would all happen in like 2008. i
don't remember the date but but then you
know conveniently said my interfering
with the timeline could change things or
something like that
2004 is when he thought it was going to
happen and he made that claim in 2000
2001 he said he was from 2036.
well it didn't
so maybe someone went back in time and
stopped it from happening
robert asks does gab have its own email
service
no but we have been asked about that a
lot we do we did have to build our own
email system
so we got banned from like uh mail gun
and all those services that you can you
know send mass emails we had to stop
everything that we were doing for about
three months and build our own email
system just to be able to send people
password resets confirmations all that
type of stuff just basic transactional
emails we had to build our own dude
that's so dangerous you think they could
do that to any human at any time
people need to understand that um
auto response emails are not a simple
thing
we we so when we launched our website we
didn't i didn't i didn't realize how
quickly it would grow and it grew so
incredibly rapidly i was surprised so i
love all of you guys it's amazing and
then all of a sudden we had to deal with
you know um confirmation emails account
emails and then all of a sudden we're
dealing with like 30 000 emails in only
a couple days and our system locks and
then we're like we don't know what's
going on we didn't realize we were going
to hit by that much and then people are
complaining and canceling and i'm just
like
well i have no idea what's happening
yeah that's part of why like rapidly
expand infrastructure as we're building
our open network i'm like building the
website and i'm like i can't put a phone
number on there i can't put an email i
mean maybe i can't even put an email
address on there in good conscience
because it's going to get annihilated
with content so it's
but i understand how how do you contact
facebook they don't want you to be able
to contact them because they're 100
million hits or whatever so how do you
guys do it oh man god bless our support
team that's all i have to say uh you
know we have a great support team uh
they they help people on the site we
have an email people can reach out to
the email we try to get back to as many
people as we can but you know we're
human beings here i mean gab is a
family-run business a lot of the people
that are you know running the support
emails and stuff it's like my brothers
my dad works for the company i mean it
really is a family-run business i you
know we don't have the top professionals
in the world but i have people that i
trust right that is the most important
thing that's one of the hardest
challenges that we have is hiring
because it's like who do you trust right
and i trust my family right more than
any anybody else on this planet so when
i say gab is a family-run business i
mean it my whole family works for gab
this is a good question here from let's
see what is this
comic nut he says this is probably
either a stupid question or a brilliant
one i think it's brilliant if facebook
is experimenting on people without their
knowledge doesn't that violate the
nuremberg code
let's read the nuremberg code well i
think that only applies to governments
but it is interesting that we've now
what allowed
facebook to bypass
human rights protections
because the nuremberg code says that if
there's going to be an experiment people
have to be informed and consent to to be
involved in nuremberg codes a set of
research ethics principles for human
experimentation i think that's like
what's the first what's the first
provision or whatever
yeah read that one okay ten points of
the nurnberg the first one's the
voluntary consent of the human subject
is absolutely essential
wow what's the penalty for violating it
i don't know the penalty for violating
the nurse is there one i don't know does
it apply to governments only or to
companies too at this point i think
corporations are functioning as
governments and maybe should be held
yeah accordingly penalty to nuremberg
code
all right
a real nick says what is gabb's five
year plan
save free speech on the internet it's
that simple well you know what we're
doing now is we're working on you know
what i'm calling the parallel economy
this is something i've been talking
about for about a year now and and
building the tools to empower that
parallel economy so we have gab pay
which is our paypal alternative we have
gab marketplace which is our facebook
marketplace ebay etsy alternative so
what we're doing is we're empowering
people to you know engage in commerce
we've created and we've protected free
speech we've enabled that and inevitably
what we see happen is when you have an
area where you have free speech free
markets tend to develop and we're seeing
that happen organically and naturally on
gab right now and we want to be able to
provide the tools for people to do that
in a much better way in an easier way so
that's what we're working on now
parallel economy man i've warned about
that years ago because it's a precursor
to civil war
or
fracturing or divorce or maybe that's
what they want you to think
no but it it is parallel economics when
when you have we've we've seen it around
the world when you have two groups that
isolate each other what do you have and
then start training they stop trading
amongst each other right then they start
what if you have a hundred thousand
parallel economies that's different it's
two parallel economies i can see the
heavy weight but a thousand a hundred
thousand of them maybe that's that's the
point as long as there's lines between
different factions that are connecting
them then you don't get that conflict
breakout i think it's impossible to
create a totally isolated i'm not going
to do anything you know it's it's almost
impossible this is the system is so
interconnected right
you know if you're going to start a
business you're inevitably going to do
business with people who don't share
your values it's just almost unavoidable
what we can do is make a good faith
effort to spend your money and spend
your time uh you know with places and
with people and with businesses that
share your values i think and that goes
a long way
i found a couple of people that were
found guilty of violating the nuremberg
code at the end of the nuremberg trials
uh carl brandt adolf hitler's personal
physician execution
uh rudolph brant
colonel in the ss execution i imagine
that the penalty for violating the
nurburgring was execution at that point
but they were also nazis yikes
all right stephen robertson says tim the
correct answer is go to your local skate
shop love the show always asking the
hard questions check it out gab now
right on uh yeah if you you
provide a patronage to your local skate
shops avoid the mall shops if you can uh
you know i don't want to hate on them
all ships necessarily i appreciate
anybody who's selling gear but you know
small businesses is where it's at you
know unless they have like i'll tell you
if i went to a local skate shop and then
a mask mandate i'd go to the mall but
the mall the mall had a mass made it was
really funny i went to zoomies and i had
a bubble tea and i had my mask on this
was this was like last year and so i
walk in and i take the mask off one ear
and start sipping the drink and they go
hey you got to put your mask back on and
i was like i'm drinking bubble tea in
the mall that i bought at the kiosk
outside your store and they're like
doesn't matter you got to wear the mask
they were like stick the straw under
your mask i remember that i was just
like how does that make sense and i was
like whatever dude i don't need to drink
my bubble tea and i just want i was like
i don't need to shop here i just walked
out of the store it's insane
i got some um i was thinking about uh
people making masks with straw holes in
them if it ever got to that point i
don't think people did that they have
zippers on them insane with the nurbur
code it looks like it's talking about
medical experimentation that that's what
specifically yeah no person should be
forced to take a medical experiment
without informed consent although is
psychological experimentation medical
experience i would say so i would think
it's messing with your mental they were
making people depressed they were
showing them negative stuff to try and
cause pain like that's crazy dude at
least that's what i read on the internet
yeah yeah we know it's true they were
like changing to the color of the page
and stuff to give them different
emotions no they were they were putting
they were uh having having the feed send
them negative content like police
brutality and something that that's
that's the experiment look
i got to be careful you know fact check
that i don't know exactly what they were
posting but my understanding based on
what i read was that could be wrong this
is facebook i know what you're talking
about look it up
all right
what is this one
roger says tim and luke i want a gorilla
action figure that says random luke isms
when you hit a button on his back i like
that idea or like a luke action figure
that it'll it'll say something funny
like exacerbate yes
like i was saying that in today's show i
knew exactly like
i just could i was like i almost started
laughing all right everybody we are
going to head over to our members only
podcast we start recording right now so
go to timcast.com become a member sign
up if you want to support the work we do
on this show if you want to support our
journalists and if you want to watch the
after show and our massive library of
content we've had people on like you
know um steve bannon alex jones big big
names mike rowe for instance really
great conversations marjorie taylor
green so go to timcast.com become a
member follow the show at tim cast irl
basically everywhere you can follow me
at tim cast basically everywhere which
includes on gab and uh uh andrew you
want to shout anything out uh get on gab
gab.com
uh by the way if you wanna get our app
since we're banned from the app stores i
think this is important go to
help.gab.com and it'll show you how to
get the app on ios and android
right on nice andrew you got me with
that uh ron paul answer i signed up
to gab my account is the same one on
twitter and instagram luke we are change
luke we are change on gab i'm gonna try
out your platform i like uh all the
answers that you gave us so i appreciate
your time i also have my own independent
media organization called we are change
i released a really important video
about what's happening in russia today
on youtube.com forward slash we are
change hope to see some of you guys
there and uh thank you for that
conversation thanks for having me great
man um okay so i did confirm facebook
data scientists manipulated the news
feed of almost 690 000 users showing
them positive objectives and negative
ones unknown in 2012.
690 000 people that's a lot of people
and this is not the only experiment
they've done on the i'll we can maybe go
into this later there's a lot yeah and
this is what they made let's get into
the member segment we'll talk about the
evils of these companies thank you guys
so much for coming ian crossland.net i'm
ian crossland check you later and i am
sarah patrick i'm gonna have to get on
to gab i usually use mines as my
alternative media platform i just
realized i haven't logged into facebook
since before christmas it's like a phone
so i'm uh strong on that one uh you guys
may follow me on twitter at sarah patch
lids
and gab when you get on oh yeah we will
see you all over at timcast.com
the show should be up around 11 or so
p.m thanks for hanging out we'll see you
there
you